on my birthday i became a regular at the
store [ __ ] yeah that's wow 20 years i'll
be a regular in [ __ ] uh three weeks
huh
how many times you get in front of her
it just takes twice
first time that she say anything like
now you have 10 minutes to come back
next time
and i remember coming to the store had
my references and they said
it's a six week backlog
six six seven sometimes four or five
months okay i accepted it
friday they called me said listen to
cancellations you win
i was in
three minutes
to come back and do ten
you're a regular
fat baby fat baby oh god
i still have pictures of lineups if
you're a baby it took like three years
for her to start calling me fat baby
ready let's do it let's do it
the church of what's happening now
is presented by on it
this show is brought to you by mvmt
watches
mvmt watches
makes minimalist products at
revolutionary prices with over 500 000
watches sold check out get yours today
go to mvmtwatches.com
church to get 15 off with free shipping
and free returns that's
mvmtwatches.com church
the show is also brought to you by helix
sleep
go to helixsleep.com where you can buy
mattresses online customized for you for
hundreds of dollars instead of thousands
go to helixsleep.com
joey right now to get fifty dollars off
of your order that's helixsleep.com
joey
the show is also brought to you by cso
stream all the comedy you want anytime
anywhere for only 3.99 a month ceso is
the comedy you crave
go to cso.com and enter promo code joey
right now to get one month for free
that's cso.com promo code joey
oh [ __ ]
[Music]
kick that merely kick that [ __ ]
it's monday baby it's january 30th
[ __ ]
we're taking this muffler to the hoop
tonight deep in the murky waters
oh [ __ ]
steve ren is easy [ __ ] yeah joey the
flying jew
and uncle joey
this is the [ __ ] shankler's guitar
he's [ __ ] that german is [ __ ]
killing that guitar
oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ]
just when you thought it was safe and
you out of the woods the big bad wolf is
back [ __ ]
what's happening you bad [ __ ] i
missed you it was a great long weekend
with the family i didn't see lisayet
this weekend at all he had him in
seclusion over there
canyon
the wife sucked him in friday he was
done
ah he was eating stars over there
getting stories about attorneys and [ __ ]
oh they were setting presidents at his
house it was all over oh it was uh
i mean i got nervous taking stars with
uh with cold medicine oh nothing
happening
that's the whole way listen you popped i
think a little half a glass of nyquil
with some rocks oh my god couple [ __ ]
rocks with a taste of [ __ ] gin in
that [ __ ] and you eat two stars
the [ __ ] flu goes away
there's a thing my old father-in-law
used to make
as soon as you got sick as soon as you
said i don't feel good
he would put like brandy hot toddies
right no no something polish like brandy
and honey and lemon juice and paprika
and [ __ ]
celery sticks and [ __ ]
it tasted terrible but you did one shot
first of all you lasted like 20 minutes
after that you went down down
what the [ __ ] you were
i don't care how much crystal meth you
have you're going down from this drink i
would just drool and [ __ ]
and then uh
i never had it again i don't know what
the [ __ ] it's called and then he used to
call it something polish and it just
knocked the [ __ ] right out of you
knocked this [ __ ] right out of here [ __ ]
you listerine and it was everything was
in there it was like four ounces i had
that neurovirus over christmas it was
terrible where'd you get it from i i got
it from i think one of the i did a show
up in syracuse at that funny bone you
know you meet and great after i think
one of the savages up there gave it to
me
you know handshake by the time i got
home it's fine two days later i'm out
dinner with
ari i go home i start to throw up i text
him i go is this you feel bad he goes no
so i'm like [ __ ] i got it just out the
ass the mouth the whole thing then
everyone else down the line gets it it's
terrible people have no idea
how sick you get from traveling every
week if you let it get you and
if you get sick one week and you have
like two weeks after that
by the time you get back you got full-on
bronchitis yeah
soft pneumonia
i always tell you people that i learned
from other comics
you know i learned i saw him get sick
all the time ralphie made the beginning
he would get sick all the time guess
what he was doing smoking a pipe with
people
yeah and every week you go into these
different areas
and he was getting this jungle right out
of his lungs he ended up in the hospital
[ __ ] i love smoking weed but i tell you
what if i got like a busy week like if
i'm shooting something i don't smoke
weed with people on the road i can't
take the [ __ ] chance because they
don't give a [ __ ] yeah they don't give a
[ __ ] about your life they give a [ __ ]
about going to the show and meeting you
and i don't blame them
but you have to consider if you had
bronchitis for three [ __ ] weeks yeah
and you come to the show don't smoke a
joint with me dog don't smoke a joint
with eight people don't pass a pipe
around you know better than that i know
they just don't want to lose the
experience after the three hits then
they go off from you out on time now
you're like they look at you and they go
oh i had bronchitis
thank you you [ __ ]
now i'm not gonna smoke with nobody
because of you because all it needs is
one bad apple to spoil a whole bunch
especially joints yeah joint balls you
can kind of i i don't mind doing in
front of people when you kind of burn
the ends and [ __ ] but no yeah but you're
still in it listen would you trust me i
eat [ __ ] chicks
i don't know you know what i'm saying
yeah i don't trust nobody
there was a girl i smoked a couple weeks
ago i'm like how many dicks did this
chick sucked the last month
i'm a dick sucker by proxy just from
smoking from this [ __ ] thing
what's up lisa
oh my god i feel like i'm already going
through change i don't know what those
[ __ ] uh chocolates do
oh my god i don't know you guys cuz you
know why because this is why you [ __ ]
around every weekend
i tell you to go deep on friday and
saturday
you're in training and you [ __ ] around
steve i did 150 milligrams 11 000 this
is 1500 i'm we're doing tonight
right
this is like watching michael phelps and
and his trainer
we're doing
but you on the weekend you [ __ ] around
yeah doing your [ __ ] yeah you have to
take another start now that that's
another star all right the penalty is a
star penalty it's a stop penalty for
[ __ ] around this weekend instead of
training i ate everything i even ate the
50 milligram stars i had
i had like 10 blue ones in the drawer
that were older than [ __ ]
gummier you had a [ __ ]
how do they just throw it at me and i
caught it landed right on oh my god
stuck to him doug he's like [ __ ] uh
what's that guy when we were kids the
receiver from oakland less than a
molester
he used to spray himself down with that
spray before the nfl slippery whatever
that didn't work oh the [ __ ] sticks oh
the stick um stuff oh my god lee this
guy put a video on less than a molester
yeah
then the ball would like
stick right to him i think it stuck to
his helmet one time that was it that was
like dog you gotta stop it what should i
search lester the molester no lester
hayes was like that pine tar stuff this
stuff that george brett went nuts about
all over his shirt a couple years ago he
came out he hasn't even had to work the
computer right
when the best dance sports show was on
rich williams great kid remember
richmond yeah good writer yes kid from
syracuse as a matter of fact
george brett came on the show and they
wrote a sketch
of me and george breton what really
happened and it was me and the dugout
eating a sundae
with hot fudge and it went all over the
back that was the pine tunnel
it was me he was a good dude too
but so funny how i started on that show
with those guys they contacted me the
pay was garbage
but it was enjoyable like i've got to
meet sugar atlanta they dress me up like
roberto duran
and then like go down there and insult
him and sugar ray leonard he's been
punching the head 18 times he couldn't
[ __ ] tell at first you can see he was
looking at me going is this really
roberto what the [ __ ] damn
wait what's going on over there it's
right here here we go
watch how he played like
a stick em yeah this was it this was
this is crazy [ __ ] people for people
don't know it was like a
a thing that you sprayed on you
this is a [ __ ] movie
this is what i'm talking about people
this is what i'm talking about
lester hayes please
look
no that's the [ __ ] haze please this
falcon you see hayes there
there's got to be a leicester [ __ ]
haze here i'm telling you i'm watching
hey right there most intimidating
raiders right so i put on there it is
watch this lisa yeah you're gonna
[ __ ] learn something see what i'm
saying
this is my life yeah but they're not
gonna show like the stick'm catches and
the most intimidating raiders part well
what do you think on the show they're
gonna show look at look at this guy look
at the
just looking at him you'd be scaredly
what happened to the video what happened
to the screen the tv stolen
that's a nice stolen tv though that's
what you got to say you're going to
steal one look at them look at that
yeah look at this [ __ ] on his ankles
lee you know what that is look at how
you lived the septuagint he was a great
athlete he just he was a great athlete
no matter what everyone's hand look at
his hands
the stickings all over the people's
hands but look at him he was a great
athlete to stick them helped him
just a little bit like if a ball got hit
and it threw up in the air and they
would land on his shoulder that's how
the stick them was shouldn't have been
they say those gloves now that they wear
now odell beckham they're they're
basically made of stickers yeah they're
black ones i mean
yeah they're so shiny and [ __ ] when i
used to work at the puddle car wash in
boulder
those guys
somebody at that university was just
robbing those gloves
by the boxes
i must have had 20 of those pairs of
boxes at the gloves at the house not
boxes i'm sorry
20 of those gloves and they were like
those black clothes yeah that the
receivers right yeah everybody at the
car wash
and the [ __ ] people from the universe
would come there and go why does
everybody did we pay for these
university of denver all over the
[ __ ] no boulder boulder yeah so
boulder had them and they had them like
in home colors i think like black and
gold i don't know like if they saw you
like the gold ones people would say
don't let them see you with the gold
but in those days that's how those
students that's how those football
players made a living yeah they stole
[ __ ] and sold it memorabilia statues
what are you using them for the car wash
though what do you mean like wow you got
to keep your hands you got to keep your
hands dry dry so you would wipe the cars
down
and then just to be cool if you were
staying like me i was a [ __ ] salesman
at the car wash i was not [ __ ]
i had dried windows for about a week
and that was it that was a horrible job
yeah horrible yeah i got that job like
november
28th
and i kept that job until like [ __ ]
january 10th and then right before the
super bowl i got indoors at a detailed
body shop but i was at the puddle out
there i started it's cold too
and i had a license
and they wouldn't let me drive
like that why there was a kid they paid
just to drive to pull the cars out put
them into spots right he was mr cool he
had the
hat like everybody knew who he was yeah
did you have to crack them off pieces of
your tips oh [ __ ] that i would steal
tips anybody who gave me money i
belonged to me [ __ ]
if i saw you out there with two bucks
and a ticket i'd work my angle so i was
right there oh thank you sometimes i put
a dollar in sometimes i keep a dollar
you know
you know there was always an angle there
that that was a sad thing that was
always everybody was [ __ ] stealing
from that
that place must have made millions of
dollars because when i was a kid and i
worked there
i found that [ __ ] that everybody was
robbing that play it's amazing
car washes are a really great business
to just
make money oh it's a cash business it's
a cash cow my friends had one in hoboken
when i was growing up it's a cash cow
you know and if you get it the salesman
is the whole thing really
that guy at the window when you see the
ones around here those guys why would
you hire these mexican dudes if they
can't which one do you want yeah yeah
they'll give you the regular give me
sure you don't want the 1695 dog i would
work you to pee for pieces four extra
bucks you get the whole time
i'm gonna give you the car wash
the basic car washes is [ __ ]
it's 6.95 i'm gonna charge you 6.95 for
the basic car wash but i'm also going to
do this i'm going to throw the waxing
i'm going to throw the rust
inhibitor which was nothing
rust inhibitor is like [ __ ] whatever
the spray that they spread out under the
car to shield it against salt and rock
yeah i'm going to spray stuff on your
rims i'm going to arm roll it in and out
nice i'm going to try you know i would
work them let me throw in this let me
throw on that because you figured out
what cost nothing
what cost nothing you know i went to the
boston let me ask you
what can i throw in here and make people
no no i didn't even ask them because
they're too stupid yeah they're still
going they're still working in the 70s i
don't show them joey dear style
you know i'm saying joey dia styles
taking it from a different perspective
you know when you sell cars and when you
sell
cars in denver colorado you go for gross
what is gross the amount over the
invoice you know if the sticker says 20
000 and we own the car for 17.5 i make a
living off
me making you believe that that car's
worth twenty thousand dollars if i sell
you that car correctly you're gonna get
for a little discount just to let your
friends know
but if i sell that car correctly to you
and and if i show you the lighters and i
take an hour with the bell look at this
blinker
this is worth two thousand right here
you know what i'm saying like if you
sell the car with value
you could uh
uh
make gross in new york it's such a
horror town
when i worked i didn't work for the
potemkins the poltampkins or the thieves
in new york city but that was he said
little yeah the potemkins you know that
yeah let me open up the daily news
potemkin always got a cadillac yeah
special
199 don 199 a month wait till you get
there you leave there with 300 a month
and a [ __ ] beating the black eye you
were there for 18 hours your mother
bought a car they use your son social
they don't give a [ __ ] over there
potential at least that was how it was
20 years ago that's where you went to
work yep when you wanted to make money
and not have a soul there was a lot of
those places douglas toyota when i
worked at douglas toyota
listen in 87 88 90 91 they were salesmen
making 12 grand a month these guys were
making eight bucks an hour
people like 12 grand a month joey i make
that selling shoe yeah listen these guys
would be robbing people
or making eight bucks an hour yeah
they're making 12 000 a month now those
guys had no conscience
they yes you did that then they give you
to a closer
that's the place to sell
douglas if
knowing what i know now i'd be anybody
who's 21 call me
go to douglas if it's still liner closer
you just get them wet and then you can
get responsibility how you doing steve
what's happening what are you looking
again i'm
telling you what the salad
everybody enjoy listen let's do let me
ask you a question are we going to buy a
car today
have to no no no no no
before i put you in the car
are you considering because i'm going to
work hard for you i'm going to fight
this [ __ ] this guy here this is
trump's nephew
you know what i'm saying i'm going to
hit him with a stick no protesting don't
tell nobody you take them for the ride
you bring them back
in new york you don't make money from
that you make money from accessories and
financing oh the up packages and stuff
the the rims the [ __ ] the thing the
things that come out on the sides yeah
get into alarms or things on the side
the tvs in the back they give you a
taste of financing in new york yeah
there's a lot of people they want the
whole package so they want you to sell
financing from the jump huh you're going
to pay for this steve someone
credit union what's the rate of your
credit union oh i'm sure we work with
100 banks if your credit is solid i know
100 people we work with 100 pounds 100
banks i put one [ __ ] button in now
and it's like utopia it's like if you
want a hooker and you press a button now
22 [ __ ] hook it's a pop up on your
computer same thing i got 100 [ __ ]
banks
and you tell them to give you your rate
you're gonna lie and i'm gonna lie
you're gonna say you it's nine but
you're gonna say about 8.5 i beat it
but if i got you eight today right now
with the low down payment let you keep a
thousand
use it for your son's [ __ ] football
team give it to the nun let me show you
a little monthly [ __ ] whatever the [ __ ]
it is
so how do you make money if you're the
the before the closer like if do you
have to they have to sell the car or are
you just getting paid just for doing
that okay the closure for the closure to
come in you have to get a commitment
okay what's your commitment i'm going to
buy this car i just
yeah so you want to do 300 a month i
really didn't say i
270 is what i really want to do but 2
000 all i got to do is this i got to get
you the down payment you want the price
on your trade
that you want that's all i got you get
me that and then we'll get to this card
and then and then he'll have you sign
all four boxes i got a credit card from
you and i bring it to a closer i wish
this [ __ ] animal luck and i sent them
to a guy who's been beating women for
the last 30 years of his life two
divorces yes eight divorces he doesn't
that's eighth in his softball team yeah
robbed one of them at gunpoint
this guy comes in and just torments you
to death before i mean and then he
brings you you need the gas and go
package
the gas and go package and then he
brings it a check that does the whole
introduction to the car so you already
sold another car if you're a king
by the time that guy goes to f and i and
then to the uh
they called in those days they had girls
hot girls that we show you everything
about your car explain the lease or the
the payment plan who you paid it to yeah
they don't have that anymore yes they do
well not at the volkswagen in panorama
city there well because it's very
when you have that last customer service
rep
they make sure that you listen to how
slick these dealers are
they make sure that when you get your
customer rating
you bring it back to them and let them
fill it out
and i'll not only buy you a tank of gas
but i also throw those rims you like
that
because that's the most important thing
the customer service index is the most
important thing and the most important
thing for white people
because white people go on there and
they see your customer service index is
down they don't do business with you
wait they're struggling with people you
know
before you know this is before yeah it
was almost like what was that service
this business consumer business this is
before you up no no no and they still
got it now when you buy a car a dealer
will send you a [ __ ] thing
because that score
lets you know how whether you get
certain cars
if you treat your customers shitty they
ain't gonna send you all the cars
they're gonna give you a shitty [ __ ]
allotment of cars they're gonna send you
red cars and orange cars convertibles
the lime green one though nobody [ __ ]
won so
uh that's that you have to have a high
customer rating now man you really do
it's got to be like extraordinary when i
do business with this subaru
they go above and beyond that's why i've
gotten four cars from them
i'm on my fourth or fifth or sixth car
from the valley right there yeah van
nuys bruce he comes to my shows he calls
you know
that's why i just call them and go i'm
coming up
when thursday at three happy they're
ready for me
boom i walk in no down payment because i
just go from least to least at least
yeah i'm an american dog
well i started
when i sold cars i learned more about
life than anything ever you know when
you there's certain companies you work
with that you tell them i'm gonna pay
this down payment one time but i'm gonna
get one of these every three years
yeah
i'm just commenting i'm gonna call you
at one i'm gonna pick the card before
it's watch this philly guess
i signed four papers that's what i've
seen three years after a while they'll
know you just tell them yeah that's how
i want to do business
listen whatever and now you're you're a
valued customer you're always going to
get a lease from them every [ __ ]
three years you're going to go to their
service department you know you're going
to work it they work with you bro i've
always bought cars i've never leased a
car no no no no more that ends
that ends now can you write off a lease
a little bit on your taxes a ton of [ __ ]
because i'm making you pay for what you
die why are you paying for the whole
thing look what's going on with society
today look what's going on with my man
here ever since i've known my man
he's broke it down for me and then
between him and my other brother
they'll [ __ ] sit you down and talk to
you 22 ways why are you up to cut cable
today
yeah and what the scam is and what the
source they do they cut it all the way
down they got chinese got chinese cable
that's got stolen from the israelis
and it gets shipped to new jersey okay
and then he gets like hbo go for three
dollars a month he gets the espn package
with his little [ __ ] things no hbo he
doesn't need ask him that's the today's
america these are watching tv for 25 a
month and there's americans still paying
100 that's me though i'm the american my
dad's on my passport
sometimes i go who's watching the sneaky
pete's without me how good is it my dad
i'm i'm just one in but my dad's like i
could i go you gotta
go back to the one that i was on
it's one account you can't just keep
moving like he's five ahead
my entire family's on my all my accounts
too yeah my mom watches like gilmore
girls i'm like who's watching come on
this kid eliminated the cost yeah his
television yeah okay so the same
i'm paying 180 bucks a month dude i'm a
nerd i love tv
i i when i first got a tv in my room
because i wasn't allowed to in through
my entire life i didn't sleep i had espn
the sports center the bars on the left i
had it burned into my tv because it was
i would just have it on all night
and i haven't had cable for about two
and a half years
still you haven't i haven't had i
haven't had cable i've had netflix i
have uh cody a little bit but not really
even that much i have uh amazon see so
for some specials
and uh and then a lot of the other stuff
you can just buy on on demand now well
you you lease what depreciates and you
own what appreciates
so whatever loses money why would you
buy i buy 20 000 for a car i go down the
corner it's worth 18.
already now i just got 20 g's in this
[ __ ] car
okay then you have the option of
financing if you have great credit you
go down and put a percentage down and
get like a cheap union rate or something
six points and you can save money that
way to build your credit or whatever
but after a while
and i learned this selling cars you want
the most car for the least amount of
money
when i used to pencil people which means
when i go to my manager for steve
runner's easy yeah if steve told me that
if he kept saying 250 to like the best
deal ever
like as an american to [ __ ] my
brother like if my mother came to me
in 1989
90 in that time and said to me papa what
kind of car would you hook me up with
nissan at one time
had a deal on this medium car
what's that rocket ship in the middle
ultimate altima no
bigger than that one the one maxima yeah
yeah what the maximum nissan maxima
nissan altima maxima
when i was [ __ ] selling cars
they had a deal that you could only
unless you're [ __ ] stupid
you wouldn't go down there
first of all when you buy a car
you own the car for five years not the
five years then you own the [ __ ] car
so for five years the bank owns that
[ __ ] note by the time you own that
car you don't even want that [ __ ] car
no more it smells like the [ __ ] your
ex-girlfriend used to blow you in the
car she's not with another guy
you know it's ridiculous
but now we have so much invested that we
want the most out of this car in our
mind this car is worth all this money
and then we go try to sell the
neighborhood now we're stuck with that
[ __ ] car listen as an american you
want to trade your car every three years
every three years fifteen thousand a
year
bam i don't do no more driving to fifty
thousand a year no more
now not really since when our driving
days are over with san diego was the
only place we drive i don't go san
francisco no more i don't know you fly
to san francisco yeah so if you keep
your mileage low
why buy when you can rent that's all at
least is
so now instead of you paying 450 a month
i'm gonna give you the same car for 300
a month
for 36 [ __ ] months you know
four thousand you know how to put down
and get that number
put 2500 back in your pocket excuse me
1500
really and in three years you come in
here and [ __ ] get another three talk
to your accountant it may not work for
you but abe lincoln the great abe
lincoln said
lease one appreciates
and
no own what appreciates and leaves what
depreciates [ __ ] yeah a blanket think
you're dealing with it that wasn't this
so here's mine why come to the church i
i've been leasing this is my second
lease and both times i've paid for the
extra miles please thank you i paid for
the extra miles and and you never get it
well i got close
mostly but now i live so close to where
i am most of the time i think i did
under 10 000 last year
so like but then someone was telling me
you [ __ ] up because this [ __ ] guy
gets a call from them this is how they
get you
they get these [ __ ] dudes they call
him after the lease is two years old
and they say come down we got too much
inventory give us your call when i stand
out here and you go down that's where
they [ __ ] with the numbers
i don't [ __ ] love them really yeah i
waited three years you dropped the car
off now i got it so good i dropped the
car off
okay
they cut me a check for the miles
and when i get a ch a bill from subaru
i send them that check
you know how many bills i've gotten from
subaru
dog it pays to be loyal with one company
that's it
i don't care if it's bmw you lose the
bmw the shitty one the three
just because you want to be cool it's
dirt cheap
that's why you see thousands of [ __ ]
bmws because people go down they're
going i want to buy a bmw
and also they go you know what the
number is on that
it's this every month it's a small
nickel you know what i'm saying plus
you're 21. all right you're 21. what do
you think insurance gonna bang you
that's another g bow a month you're
paying [ __ ] 16 just to drive the car
why are you killing yourself i know do
me a favor my dad always bought the cars
and then he would give him down to the
kids and stuff
yeah and when your kids ready for a
thing you put them on a scooter you know
[ __ ] it you put them on one of those
italian scooters with a [ __ ] vespa
yeah a little vespa beeping at people
cutting people off hammer hanging out
how is it being a dad and balancing your
career it's i mean
it's tough
um what so long as you've been away from
a month oh jesus christ yeah where'd you
go i did a movie in shreveport for it
was like three and a half weeks
it was yeah two three weeks yeah 20 days
20 days 20 years two days it was tough
at this point in my life i think it's
four days and it'll
yeah i think it's four days and i would
lose it without it just
i think if i came to it right now i was
like hey i got something a movie that
shoots in london for 10 they need me for
10 days i think 10 days would be okay
two weeks would get like an eye roll
like i remember going on the road for
six weeks in a row
i leave thursday and i come back sunday
yeah like there's a nick game i want to
go see
yeah and take one of my boys in the city
who grew up together you know take them
go from kalamata through these [ __ ]
smoke a few joint give them a few stars
and take them to the [ __ ] nickname oh
that's perfect for the garden you know
but that means i got to be away from
them for all week yep i could still
train jiu-jitsu tuesday and wednesday i
go to nyack how was that club the levity
live yeah nice it's in the mall it's the
mall it has to hold everything cool how
close to the thing down the down the
it's a highway in between so it's like
two exit off the highway you know that
it's right by the tappan zee bridge
that's the one thing
i don't know if you're gonna drive there
from taking jfk but drive up you see
that you drive over the new tappan zee
bridge almost it's right next to it the
tappan zee bridge was one of the worst
bridges well they just rebuilt in the
[ __ ] country they were scared for
years yeah
people living in fear going over that
[ __ ] thing
no one ever told me this i went over the
table i struggled with that i saw a
documentary a few years ago so they
built a new one right next to it so
they're almost they're done with it so
then they're gonna blow up the tappan
zee when i was a kid i don't know
we used to get on nine w
uh-huh just stop by the henry hudson
parkway i said that no 9w on the jersey
side you go up uh
you go to fort lee you go behind fort
league kind of sort of correct me people
you know it's been [ __ ] 20 something
[ __ ] years
and you go up and you pass some car
dealerships you passed the old bicycle
club you passed like englewood uh
mazda and whatever you just keep going
straight and also you get on the road 9w
and you go up 9w
and 9w
jesus christ your worst [ __ ] ari
sophia mike tesla uh
you went up there and on saturday nights
there was a place called the cuckoo's
nest we were
seniors in high school uh-huh and we
would get [ __ ] up do powder and go
let's go for a ride and four puerto
ricans will get in the car and we all
shoot up to
the cuckoo's nest and [ __ ]
and i'll never forget the hindu he
this
[Music]
the door guy was a hindu with a wig
like you couldn't write this you
understand me not just the top piece
what kind of wig like the wig like the
whole thing like this sideburns but it
was a it was a 10g 15g wig in 1982. this
thing was persian you know what i'm
saying perfect this was [ __ ]
beautiful and he had a goatee
and he was very nice you know and uh
i had some
monday night football they'd give you
you know this is 1982 people 81
they give you uh
six beers for a dollar a bucket in a
bucket filled with ice you'd go up there
on monday nights wings leave you with
half time right oh wings all night and
those days at monday monday night
football nothing pisses me off more
as this is how bad this country is
we lost monday night football
i know joey you've talked about it
before no you don't monday night
football was so strong i know
[ __ ] who got eight balls on
monday nights my dad won hooker not
hookers but strippers are coming half
time
guys i'm telling you money you people
losing strippers i know [ __ ]
that wouldn't go out on friday i know
[ __ ] never get the schedule
for monday and football to plan their
weekends they take their wives out on
friday night i'm gonna give up i don't
mind going out friday night we're going
out friday night but you know what can
you just watch monday night i gotta get
a little early i gotta bring some food
people got fired because of monday night
football
the totals were insane first of all you
stayed up to watch it
you know if you're a kid in new england
you're 13
during the
it's the last game against the jets and
they go to the playoffs lee syed is
staying up until one in the morning
watching overtime absolutely the game
starts at nine
yeah the game starts at nine in new york
you know that's what people in the six
o'clock we're so lucky it starts at six
here i know by nine we go out and do our
thing
back there you gotta wait till nine by
seven thirty what about with baseball
and uh not to change the subject but
with baseball when the east coast team
played a west coast team and it started
at 10 30 to 11 o'clock sometimes a rain
delay oh yeah yeah yeah yeah no when i
was a kid all those like when the knicks
played this yeah the seattle supersonics
yeah same thing yep you really like it
will come on like a 10-30 we're turning
into wor right now
yep but monday lost my i remember people
eating quick leave we were bar hot
just that we would go up there on
mondays but my all-time favorite was the
place in englewood clinton
englewood nothing with
something like it was a chain
and on monday nights they put meatballs
off and wings
dude half time boundaries
if you gotta and all you had to do is
get like a pitcher of beer and they gave
you like a knife a fork
and a plate lead and you just tore up
wings for four quarters endless blue
this is way before ranch was invented
nobody used ranch in those days it was
straight up blue cheese they have like a
little salad which nobody thought nobody
touches you go there eat those wings
with a with a gram of coke burn the hole
in your pocket this is your last meal
for the next day and a half and [ __ ]
[ __ ] gold jackets oh my god there'd
be piles of wings i just love that just
to remind everyone in case you have any
new listeners this is in high school
this isn't like joey's just turning 21
and in college this is joey in like
sophomore year but here it is no no this
is this started maybe my junior year
i built these [ __ ] up i can't
remember the name not bottom of the
barrel
that was a mob bar this was something
else it was a chain and it was the
middle of this thing and people going in
we could get wings beef steak charlie's
no no i was in new york city yeah
yeah
there was [ __ ] fist fights in there
the steak was always alive like yeah it
made some type of noise well done
was older than [ __ ]
that aluminum four was from like 1910
pittsburgh wasn't even [ __ ] on the
map yet
oh my god that place stunk but you know
what dog for 20 bucks you ain't like you
[ __ ] stop that you could bring your
whole family to god if you were savage
you get the buckets i never saw fist
fights but i didn't hear about fishing
in the parking lot when they gave crab
legs out white people would go bananas
in those days discount steakhouse yeah
it was like a beefsteak charlie oh my
god
people say like stuff is bad now but at
least marketing has gotten better beef
steak
charlie's was the bomb 10 wings when we
were in high school football we'd go
there oh my god yeah but i was just
reading something today i wasn't
reading for 2017 it was one of those
slide shows and they said they have
like free food at a bunch of bars in new
york like you can just go in and with
like every drink you'll get a pizza like
a slice of pizza really on like fridays
one place has like a wing buffet and i
never see that anywhere like th do you
remember that i know you've talked about
like the sandwiches of joe and mary's
but
like for foreign when i was growing up
on that side of jersey i could look in
the face and tell you any place you went
into
had something on the bar food wise in
the 70s you always had something on the
bar i used to go to this one place
in union city
my friend's uncle worked there
and i never forget going down like on a
tuesday night watching college
basketball six people at the bar
hey come over to you you're hungry
hey at least something yeah and he came
back with mortadella and adam cheese and
cuban crackers what with some cervezas
are you [ __ ] kidding me who shows up
with mortadella adam cheese on cuban
crackers this guy was irish
he was as irish as they came [ __ ] yeah
you know those type there was places
where they always had some yeah like
food thing in the back that chance place
i talk about
they're legendary because they were
professionals yeah if you went to the
bar during the week and that bartender
was there and he took a blast from you
and he let your karate chop and all that
[ __ ] but that was the that was the my
time that was my the other place the
bartender you gave him ten dollars you
karate chopping from time to time come
on over here
i think okay
he didn't even give you his neck
all right he even give me his
my
next
roger used to karate chop but back to
monday football
i built a relationship with this
restaurant
i would walk in there every monday night
with four or five six deep
and we'd eat 200 wings believe it
we leave a 20-hour tip
we never got into those fist fights or
nothing
so for maybe a year and a half i had a
relationship up there they trusted me
go back to 1985
i would mug you for a dollar right
i would walk in there and they would
still go hey hey
i would eat wings have a couple
margaritas maybe a salad
maybe a bloody mary and i'd take the
check and leave a 10 on the table and
i'd run out of that with
really i did that every [ __ ] week and
i'll have my brother calling him george
george goes no he was great
i would actually go up to the manager
with the tab
wrinkled up in my hand and talk to him
like no [ __ ] yeah service was
sensational
i guess before computers you could do
that yeah yeah this is all before
computers this is way and you know i was
so good at i thought that was my high
point of disgusting thievery
yeah i couldn't rob big places probably
walk into buildings with a suit on and
rob like a bank box from a [ __ ] under
that's like an office building
the secretary would get up to go pee i'd
go right in there go into the draw and
there would be the cash box you never
know sometimes there's eight dollars
sometimes it's 800 you know what i'm
saying
you gotta take a chance better than
sitting on the couch looking for water
you're coming down the elevator with a
catch box
bro cash you don't know how many
jackpots i had
that i would walk off the elevator walk
out of the building the security guard
be right there like oh jesus christ
but i'd have a suit on yeah you look
professional look at this shoe i don't
have a [ __ ] briefcase
i mean i used to have a briefcase just
like this leather
doctor's pouch and i used to go to the
safeway in the mornings and fought late
and the overstock
they would hide it
under the shelves and on top of the
product
so the big product in those days was
yeast infection paste if you took it
you know the [ __ ] you put on your yeast
infection if you took it into upper
manhattan and harlem the beginning
they give you a top dollar for those
tubes
so every morning i've been [ __ ] going
there on the way over the city this is
this is my creepiness this is this is
even
i was doing comedy and doing this for
you kid
1990 [ __ ] three i was put on this
game with a suit on every morning just
to get into the city i would leave my
house with zero would listen to me
that's a true business man you're going
out listen
to this job on craigslist
i was on the discipline i would leave
the house with zero dollars and had to
get into new york city to midtown
and have breakfast and get some ways
and some more scored joint something you
know what and in my mind i knew if i get
into the city
and get downtown i could score breakfast
put it on the arm at nikki the greeks
you know saying like you knew people
along the way you had eaten there so
yeah but how are you gonna okay how are
you gonna get all those i would put a
suit i get up in the morning
put the [ __ ] thing in no no no no i'm
a professional i would walk right the
safeway
look around the showers there'd be no
security at seven in the [ __ ] morning
they don't come until about eight nine
and i take two [ __ ] yeast infection
boxes
whatever and there was something else
they wanted like they didn't want
tylenol they'd buy from you or any of
those aspirins they'd buy from you but
they wouldn't give you a top dollar
there was two things that were top
dollar yesterday
yeah so i would take whatever i always
go for the yeast infection juice
and in those days in the suit lisa 32
whatever i was i would walk over to the
uh george washington bridge
walk over it walk over i did that three
thousand times look over it that's a big
that's a long break it's a long bridge
not a mile and a half yeah really i
would take my [ __ ] 20 [ __ ] minutes
got your business suit business
briefcase i had the whole scam i go to
the bodega why not just take the bus
they give me because why waste time 1.50
he had zero dollars he's already the
only way i could get on that bus is if i
got on didn't pay
those buses that you pay on the way out
and run out the back door one of my
three yeah what i'm saying what am i
doing a business suit i'm in a business
suit i can act like one dude
no one ever thought you were going to
jump off the side i've always i don't
like that [ __ ] no no i did it all the
time
and i'd walk under and i'd walk like two
blocks into like 180th and there was a
bodega there you walked in you put your
product on
the guy would say 35 25 now i got too
much of this uh give me ten dollars okay
boom whatever 60 bucks that's all i need
to get the party started 60 bucks i'd
walk two blocks south over the broadway
there's a cuban joint [ __ ] it's eight
in the morning good enough for cuban
food i'd bang on a cuban sandwich a
potato or mamey you know what i'm saying
then i'd take like a three block walk
past the presbyterian the upper
manhattan one yeah whatever that is and
then hop on the [ __ ] a train the
express downtown
boom there i am another [ __ ] little
hike but before that hike i take a
little detour because there's a guy that
sells nickel bags really like 15 dollar
bags what the [ __ ] you saving me like
all the
my favorite is that he had two
breakfasts before at 8 a.m he had his
breakfast in the city you got to get
ready no no i didn't have nuts i left
the house with hunger always hungry i
thought you had breakfast in the morning
there was no break no i would have
i said uh could go to downtown and do
that there you go i would always stop
and get cuban food a little early oh
cuban steak sandwich you know my
favorite in those days was a cheese
omelette with crinkle cut fries and
white toast or butter on that
[ __ ] with a coke with ice cubes
in that [ __ ] forget the water i
don't want no water if i want water i'll
tell you get that [ __ ]
get that contamination away from me
i never drank water back really [ __ ] no
what was it was it like a thing when
people were like where they're afraid of
the water you're just like no i drink
water yeah i'm surrounded by the best
in 1993 schnapple used to make this
drink
please what was it if you remember
schnapple had this snapple schnapple had
this drink
if all the other drinks are 16 ounces
the big ones no schnapple had an eight
ounce special vitamin clear drink
that tasted really sweet and delicious
special vitamins i love them someone
said who do you think you're dealing
with joey bananas
this is 1993 and they discontinued them
but you wake up all coked up that's what
you went for i'd get one of those and
i'd be ready to go finish an apple you
know what i'm saying that's amazing i've
never heard him make this thing smaller
smaller ones than those this is one the
fat lady first hit oh yeah she called it
did the thing have a little fact at the
top still think a little bottle all
fruit natural drink energizer this was
way before they had kings singing
people lost their mind
in those days people were still on
gangster nobody was dead
i'm with the chinese your [ __ ]
schnapple is that because you were
hanging out at like uh
hash ways and just like solid deliveries
like how do you know all these weird
drinks and there was only two places
that had that snap one of them was
ashwas
and the other one was little [ __ ]
lottery place in cliffside park maybe
fairview
on that [ __ ] street there oh my god
and you would go in there get like a
lottery ticket and they had them there
was little eight ounce ones and how i
knew was because when i used to hook up
with my boy we'd go into the city
connect i'd always go let's go and pick
up two snapples to get the knight
started on the right foot what i'm
saying
you get that little juice inside here
and i think it'd really harm you
where'd you go brother
who's that me i'm gonna [ __ ] with the
producer extraordinaire
and [ __ ] consultant for the stars
samoa looking [ __ ] i grew up on long
island did you really yeah
close to those clubs smithtown smithtown
suffolk county we're about like 20
minutes into this is that where you were
born that's where i was born yeah
so it was you know it was very
suburban
but we you know
you know when i was a kid my mom we did
special k
did you ever hear that stuff special it
was a carrot whatever that was this this
is like high school 90 to 95 special
okay then 95 to 99 was high school
it was college for me
so like the 90s were the drugs that we
did
special k
i didn't really [ __ ] with that stuff but
it was because i heard it was horse
tranquilizer
but our weed was decent
no one really did coke but now you go
back they called sniff town coke heroin
all day long
because pills took over
hey did anybody watch that [ __ ] espn
about the kid from boston one nice no
what's his name oh no no no the white oh
the white
[Music]
what was his name chris heather
something like that he uh comes around
to schools he talks about heroin and all
that stuff now when he got to the
celtics and he would go to his boys
outside and get [ __ ] harry potter
pills that's who i want on the podcast
lisa
yeah that's a good one because that guy
tells the truth he told the story about
doing meth for five days
and austin the cops are behind them and
he goes oh my god thank god because he
thought people were chasing them he goes
i went to the cops like [ __ ] oh thank
god you're here these five guys are
chasing me
it was the most
i felt it like i couldn't take my eyes
off and i was supposed to be watching
something else and i was like cancel
that this is what i'm watching remember
he was talking about going outside
during like half time of that celtics
game [ __ ] celtics in his uniform like
having that you you were growing up when
all this was going on i i don't remember
from then i saw this this is an older 30
for 30 i've seen this a year or two ago
it was really good
it's uh
it's crazy like especially
i don't know i it just you don't think
it's gonna be
a nice looking white guy you just don't
some most of the time when you think
about
that like that affecting someone and it
just destroyed his life getting clean
and going back home and
like losing it again like listen as soon
as i saw it and he had it under control
mm-hmm i knew
this didn't end like this i was i was
there i was there i went to prison you
understand me i had it under control too
yeah till three days it was like
it took like a day
to get under control like seriously you
know how shamed i am of that like i just
came out of the penal [ __ ] code
i learned my lesson but you know what
i'm going for a [ __ ] taste
you think about that that's [ __ ]
creepy but you know it it's it's your
pattern bro
and when they sent them home he was done
done done once you go home
you're done you're back to those [ __ ]
hills i mean he was in like
fresno
yeah and upstate losing his mind and
fresno
you know going [ __ ] deep he
he he he was homeless i mean
yeah it was like it went for real no
that shit's real man my kids at home he
was gonna call him and finally said no
and he went he went to a rehab yeah
pills and heroin were tough in the 90s
man
bro heroin's been tough
for the last [ __ ] 80 years man
it's destroyed lives man yeah it really
has
and you know it's nice to watch bumpy
johnson the day i i loved american
gangster
and i loved all that [ __ ] but
i remember new york city in the late 60s
and 70s i remember
going to my mom's dry cleaners and
those were the bad people in those days
those were the people that were going
into your business in those days with a
gun
and go and give me your money with those
people that you'd see nodding on the
corner
waiting for the light to change and all
of a sudden they'd wake up
and they'd look around and they'd
straighten their faces zombies
and they'd walk across the street and
then they'd stop again somewhere they
smoked a cigarette and they'd fall half
asleep and you would see this as a child
they saw this [ __ ] i'm like wow
and my mom would call them decatus
that's what you called heroin people in
those days really they got those
that's i mean it was so out of cheap
three dollars
done
done two three times
you go downtown in those days to
chinatown
when i was a kid i knew i had a friend
that mingled in heroin he wasn't like i
didn't hang out with him he was much
older than me you know what i'm saying
but
i would go down there with him
and it was tremendous
it was tremendous because i was a kid
and i had a partner and he would
walk us into a bar and buy his beers and
a bowl of chili and garbi back
order me something and he'll [ __ ]
leave he'd go company come back and then
he'd give us money and go go across the
street to washington square park and
we'd walk across the street and we'd get
up to eight values for ten dollars
and come back and then we'd eat the
chili drink the bee and he dropped us
back to jersey we were like his decoy we
worked him he was a plum
god rest his sword he was my goomba i
loved him quaaludes is the one i wish i
i never did a quail but i wish i could
tremendously i heard tremendous you just
like one or two and you just were
[ __ ] set what happened was again like
everything i see
the quail the [ __ ] mbma the [ __ ]
uh jerry's kid what was it was what were
you doing in college the special okay
okay all that [ __ ] is just uh
it's a different name for the series
it's a different name for the same
similar product yeah that they've just
mixed and added you know it was what
about ecstasy is that that's something
to see they added heroin to it and it
gives you this weird thing and people
were dying people sweating at that what
the [ __ ] knows you know
it's all it always started with the same
thing the quaalude was like a
pharmaceutical yeah
what would happen was
this interesting that you brought this
up
what happened was
people started pirating them you know
lee's a genius
lee went they bought four four two
quaaludes took him
got so [ __ ] high he goes i want to
know i want in on this he's a chemistry
student because i'm wasting my time
playing with [ __ ] monkeys and [ __ ]
you know playing with mice why don't i
give a [ __ ] if a mice gets cancer you
know yeah once i got the little uncle
joey i'm doing this to make a living
he takes that [ __ ] they would take those
quaaludes
break them down however they do it
chemically i'm not [ __ ] i don't know
nothing about this [ __ ] and they would
poke at them they were pirates
but what these [ __ ] didn't tell
you what
these things were just a tad stronger
than what you usually got
so here you are popping these pharmacy
ones
and you're having a cocktail because
they already told you but when you got
the [ __ ] thing they i looked in the
aisle and i go where you going tonight
me and paula i'm gonna go to my mom
we're gonna pop a quail listen i'm gonna
tell you this one [ __ ] time
i have one cocktail in a glass of water
and call a [ __ ] uber
i'm not please do me the favor
promise me i'm not gonna [ __ ] give
you the school as a lewd
i promise y'all but these college kids
said [ __ ] we can make the loot make them
for a dollar sell them for two
they don't give a [ __ ]
we make them for we make them for 80
cents and sell them for two what are you
nuts you buying for deuce i went
hello you walk into a barn those days
ago what are you talking to a guy like
me and go joey tell me what you think
pop it
and four minutes later i got a cocktail
because by the way you drink nobody ever
did a quail and drink water
let me get the strongest whatever you
got the bucket the garage
terminal juice oil whatever you got they
papa queen
and they get [ __ ] lit like you just
get lit but you got soft
loose
everything got really soft and all of a
sudden you started going in and out
like you'd be there you'd be giggling
and listening to the music
but you'd be going in and out in and out
in and out
until finally
you just short circuited and then the
next morning you just wake up thirsty
a chick next to you
some guy naked in front of you like it
was that
it wasn't like that for me like
it happened a few times with those
biscuits i
i started eating my first
when i get my first quail because they
stopped making them then right they just
stopped they like outlawed them but now
these genius kids like they only had the
the they got juice [ __ ] you [ __ ] they
got the blueprint but here's the problem
like i told on the joe rogan podcast
from time to time
when these guys before they became
[ __ ] pill manufacturers they didn't
get the right table
or they didn't look at the flooring
because now
all the tables
because the the flooring was off the
tables are like this so let me tell you
what happens when your table is crooked
that means when they place the pills on
that are dry
right or whatever the [ __ ] they're
making
the pills the juice drips down to the
bottom right
the quality juice jumps down to the
bottom so these pills are [ __ ] the
loose pills the [ __ ] gorilla biscuits
to the max
and these other ones are kind of dumb
they'll get like a like a 16 year old
high for an hour or two oh my god
meanwhile some guy like me is like it
didn't do nothing to me yeah right so
now let me tell you what happens you're
taking two of those ones down there
they both go into the same gorilla mix
and you sell them in the street
so 50 a gorilla mix and 50 is just
right okay
so me and you were like how do you know
which one's gorilla makes you never know
you don't know
the beauty of this me and you go out on
a friday night listen what are we doing
today we're going to joe mary's how much
you got i got 80.
i got 75 what do you want to do i don't
know man
it's an ominous what do you want to do
with 155
this guy's a nice guy he would actually
look me in the face
and believe he'd go
man listen i don't want to get too
[ __ ] up
let's just do a half grab i knew i had
him yeah what happened right there right
away i just get my shirt how much i have
graham cross 45 just give me 20. okay i
don't even pay for the first five
because i got a [ __ ] goldfish put
your money away that's mine later don't
worry about nothing i hope you got a
pencil in the paper for iou money all
right
and we take like a [ __ ]
we take like a four dollar quaalude
but it's a dud
it's one of the duds right so guys like
you and me are professional
we're kind of high but not really
now we're kind of disappointed you know
what i'm saying
so we sit there with drink a couple more
[ __ ] lila the bartender there the one
where the wig is yeah dog that was like
epileptic lisa piss on him
[ __ ] up right
she's making these vodka orange juices
that were white
we were [ __ ] 17
we were 17. these vodka armies juicers
just had to touch our oranges using the
top the rest was just [ __ ] vodka oh
and we'd be blasting those things and
that quail wouldn't hit us it would hit
us but mildly now we're gonna look at
them we gotta go into emergency
management
we gotta pop the second one
so we take that second one which is the
gorilla biscuit of death and we pop that
[ __ ] but that one takes a little
while to hit us and that time flacco
shows up what do you got what are you
holding give me another one give him the
money don't worry about nothing i'll
catch you tuesday
now we're in the bathroom in the middle
of all this ba boom we got hit with the
quaint little duck
now you're at the barn and vodka is
burping the [ __ ] thing
the room is just moving
if there's music your ears
are sensitive as [ __ ] which is really
weird to describe
you can't cover them because everybody
thinks you're [ __ ] [ __ ]
when an ambulance goes by those people
that cover their ears shoot them all
those people are just weak [ __ ] you
never cover you you stand there like a
soldier
cover your ears like a [ __ ] half a
fruitcake that's how i know what side of
the [ __ ] fence you're hanging on you
don't say
covering your ears
you don't know how many times i remember
my friend's uncle died or something no
where i was living
his mom died
and he had
his
the black suit
that he was in the way of the wake the
next day
i had moved in with the runnies mm-hmm
and uh
maybe
april of 81.
this is june of 82
july of 82 maybe something like that
may of 82.
i'm at joe mary's pruning down those
[ __ ] white
vodka harvest juices
i'm doing bumps and a little spoon a
little bottle and [ __ ] i had the whole
kit
and i'm eating those gorilla biscuits
i go home i eat a piece of chicken to
stop the spins and i sit in his favorite
chair his suit's right here and as i'm
sleeping also i wake up in the middle
and i start puking on this soup
i almost got thrown out for that one
but that was
gorilla biscuits okay then i learned you
the secret to gorilla biscuits was like
any other pill
you can't drink with it yeah
enjoy the pill that's where it gets bad
yeah when you start to mix that's what
you were already drunk though was that
bad then that's horrible horrible what
it would do
i would see [ __ ] for years right now
yeah i swear to god i would get to my
friend's mother was dying listen again
he wasn't my friend he was an associate
his mother was dying of cancer and ninth
his mother was dying to kansas since
like 78. geez let him be your friend and
those days they used to send her these
things called tumalons
f-66s this is always that was that the
number that was on the side of them
66. like the planes it was the devil but
not really you know what i'm saying it
was missing the sixth
she would [ __ ] take those pills and
sell them for 20 a piece oh my god i
remember splitting one one night oh my
god that's what the with the government
cap for the for the real sick people but
it knows that yeah but in those days my
mom had just died
that's the only thing that would kill
the pain i mean going on and
experimenting with those [ __ ] uh yeah
zombo pills and [ __ ] oh no him in those
yeah i would eat him that was a
that's right we had the janitor what's
that we had a gentleman that used to
come in from the high school he was at
our janet our high school had a very
unique janitorial system we got benny in
the jet
benny in the jet was a janitor that was
like 60. he was like grandpa from the
monsters but real tall and skinny and i
knew what his soft spot was he loved
blackberry brandy so i'm going to go up
to him
how'd you figure that out
what did you say you guys even buy
blackberry brandy every day from the
liquor store and the guy told me one day
and i figured him out that's like joey's
inside stock he's like a stock broker
who got inside information he's like
this is what your problem is we don't go
to the talk to the liquor store guys i
have homeless i
have to stay in those days inquisitive i
was kind of embarrassed i was kind of
embarrassed to be living on your couch
so the least i could do run as easy in
those days is get up and get out fold my
[ __ ] yeah you know you know what
you're blessed like you get in your
house and you wake up yeah they're
watching a game show yeah breakfast is
on the table [ __ ] sheets of stuff
yeah shout out to still on the couch i
didn't want to i wanted you to always
let me stay at your house thank you so i
would get up and you wake up and go
where did this kid go that's what i
wanted you to go yeah don't worry about
what i want i got 10 bucks let me go
hustle i go to the diner eat eggs like a
doctor right
now i got four bucks but i need six to
get into the city and get a nickel back
and you just hustle you know what i'm
saying yeah just uh
[ __ ] i don't know what i was talking
about i'm so [ __ ] no the janitor
you're saying oh all right so there's
janice so it was benny in the jet so
once i figured out that
benny was hooked on blackberry brandon
hey brandi i would see him in the
mornings and go benny i got a bottle of
blackberry brandy i'm holding for you
till later when when later
we can't be doing this outside
benny i'm in ninth grade benny didn't
have much what are you doing benny this
is
social studies leave me alone all right
miss gibson's doing the best in there to
try
oh my gosh so betty
betty went off the d-pad one day i
didn't give him a bottle of blackberry
after i put him through a month of torch
everything's like where's the blackberry
half emptied out and put like water in
no no no i gave him like a big bottle
like the whole pocket when the long
contact
i treat them good for like three days
you know
first day i give them like the
not the half but the full okay yeah and
he looks at me hugs me thank you where
was it because i kept telling them
somebody kept hiding their puppy
i went to a men's bed
every day he's mopping up thinking this
is gonna be five days a week i had benny
on the [ __ ] on the slide
benny's doing all your dirty work but he
was my dog benny spoke into the school
was his wife was a big shot in the
office
so if you were cool with her you were
cool with benny how big
how much of a big shot could you be
benny was in charge of janice right okay
so monday i give benny a little bottle
tuesday i give benny a big bottle
wednesday i hold him out
he gotta hold back hey you know me i
work on my good job
of like the best blackberry brandy known
to mankind
i give it to bottle okay i give him the
bottle like i ate in the morning he goes
bananas he makes like like he makes like
a noise and everything
thank you all day on the speaker betty
please
come to
betty please
come to the office we're not mad just
coming that is
like six janitors in those days that
worked like from eight to four
and then at fourth year
another journalist came in now they were
the [ __ ] they were the [ __ ] up ones
they were the ones that had like the
[ __ ] up disabilities
they heard voices [ __ ] like that those
are the ones we torch it you know
so
let me finish on betty hold on let me
take a sip of water here
we got
benny i got i forget all about betty
i get betty the [ __ ] bottle i move on
with my life hahaha you know i had him
on the hook now i owe benny because i i
had robbed the school
and i had to get back to stuff and i
didn't you know i wanted to kind of deal
with ben like
i blowed towards the windows and
got into the thing with the foyer you
know me dawg i could always figure it
out in those days oh for some blackberry
brandy you wanted him to
i wanted something from all the scales
there were the scales in those days
in the science room so we would steal
these triple beams they were 35 a piece
hot in the street anywhere 10 minutes
they went like [ __ ] hot cakes i ended
up robbing all the scales me and this
dude and we remained them nameless no
names no names joey so
so that benny one night during a [ __ ]
basketball game
third quarter the basketball game i gave
him the bottle
at [ __ ] eight in the morning this
thing
there's no way you could have drank it
guess what he drank it lee you ready for
this let me tell you what betty does lee
i'm not ready for it
during the basketball game
betty has the change to lock up the
doors
and what do you think he does he passes
out he puts chains on his hands
and he walks down the [ __ ] aisle like
he's [ __ ]
louis lamour walking on his eyebrow and
people are clapping
and people are calling betty in the jet
his eyeballs are red
he's wreaking blackberry prank
i [ __ ] up betty and the jet dog
where's tony bennett
oh my god
oh my god
did he lose his job or something
no betty retired but he was a good man
i had one
dog
i can't believe him i love him
listen i had benny i had nick the greek
two i was tormenting nixon greek
i hit him with fake snow balls and told
him i was gonna protect them
what are fake snowballs
uh somebody
who
will swear to be true
as you used to do
with me
order fake snowballs it doesn't matter
so
all right so we had that we had nick
degree
but we had
the nighttime jazz now in mckinley
school we had eagle eye we got together
what was this thing
he would walk into the gym and go all
right you guys got to get out of here
go [ __ ] yourself
you got one of those eyes that went up
and he winked
oh my gilly was rough
we were rough on those janitors there
was like three janitors there that were
kind of mental that had problems all of
them got tortured all three of them
different ways i still remember [ __ ]
that guy but now
i get to the hospital
i get to the high school and there's
this guy that
never bothered nobody
you could tell somewhere along the line
he was traumatized at a young age or
something
and he was okay he said hi to you or
something like that
i don't know what happened
one night i got caught drinking or
something like that
with another buddy of mine and for some
reason in my [ __ ] head i'm like this
[ __ ] rather inside cuz he saw us
going into the bathroom
in those days i wanted to kill my
stepdad i was pissed
i was real revenge
i didn't know how to [ __ ] this dude up i
just you know i'm saying if it was
anybody else but this dude just [ __ ]
bothered me yeah and he was a big dude
he could [ __ ] me up you know
i'm a joan marius
i'm 17 18.
i'm a [ __ ] adult you know what i'm
saying i'm robbing i'm out there
borrowing from loan sharks i'm not
paying them back
you know
now let me get the year correct i don't
[ __ ] nobody over here
so it's 83
i'm living with ferny in the basement
i'm making a little bit of money
i'm doing all right i'm on the street
narrow kind of except for friday and
saturday you know you you do you usually
end up in the city
some nights are good some nights are bad
whatever no relationships me and a guy
shed a room you know that's it that's it
he was as crazy as i was some nights we
went out together we loved each other he
was my brother
today he's got the hiv it's a [ __ ]
nightmare but not from hanging out with
me he got that afterwards banging
one friday night i'm at the [ __ ] bar
and i'm with like three or four people
and we're doing a couple bumps
who the [ __ ] knows what's on the jukebox
and then comes the jazz
like a look what we got here
so i put a beer next to him there was
like a little sandwich crate that you
could go and eat sandwich or the kids
john cowan worked next door chickadee
we had chicken delight down the corner
oh really but then we had chickadee
right next door and john would always
when the chickadee would close he would
always bring the last pieces of chicken
into the bar so they sat there all night
at night they were no good you were
cooked up nobody would touch the chicken
one time they had a birthday party they
bought an ice cream cake the cake melted
nobody touched everybody in there was
snorting coke bro it was just a coke
ball when we were kids
lila gave you [ __ ] thick drinks and
then comes his jam and he's rocking and
rolling and i'm a [ __ ] crap clep
klepto [ __ ] thief
and i walk over and i see his jacket and
i stick my hand the keys and there's
keys in one pocket and i go around them
and what do you think we got there a
[ __ ] pill case
take the pill case out i go in the
bathroom holy [ __ ] he's got like [ __ ]
15 volumes in here take all the values
out close it up put the pill cans back
in his pocket you know me
it's got like three or four different
kind of pillows in there but i got the
visas i'm good i'm like from me popping
with these v's right now at this bar at
this time you know who i am
i'm like say [ __ ] jude right now
people suck my dick for 210's right now
he had the tens with the v's in them
old school you look at those and drools
you're a professional you want to go
home and give mama a stab and that
[ __ ] horn ain't gonna work tonight
so i kept doing this every friday i
built like a little network of guys
like him and i just go up to him pick
back him take his values put him back
after about six or seven weeks [ __ ] oh
finally figured out that i was robbing
his valley
so one friday night i go in there take
his pills open them up
it's got a bunch of these white pills
they look like quaaludes just smaller
i took all
put him in my pocket
i walk out there like where's the visa
no no no he's all out of these but he's
got these
he's got baby coilers
it's winter of 83. we're at a bar
i'm not on the best of terms in the town
right now
they're all waiting for one more slip up
before i get thrown in the river we're
at a bar me and my buddies
what up what'd you get we're all coked
up we're dependent on these things it's
1 30 in the morning this is who's gonna
bring us down with this booze now we
could all go home finish our bag and
those days
we still weren't going nuts we were just
going out for a little while
and [ __ ] uh
i had these white pills
and i popped one you don't mean though i
got balls of speed i popped
and my friend's like [ __ ] let's take
them so i give them to like six of my
buddies
and i put the rest in my pocket i
[ __ ] go home steven is easy going
round three coked up to the gills with
this pill in me
i wake up the next day like at six
o'clock at night and all i do is [ __ ]
for 15 minutes
and while i'm [ __ ] as easy i'm
falling asleep
i'm starting to puke i'm drifting i'm
dehydrating i mean i'm drinking water
from the faucet
i [ __ ] i wipe my butt i drink enough
water to get me back to the bed and i go
right back to bed
the next thing i know this this light
it's monday same thing i go to the
bathroom i pee for five minutes
and everything comes out of my butt and
i just drink water wash my hands and go
right back to bed finally tuesday you
know me dog i can't sleep like that
tuesday i finally get up
and i get out of bed and i walk i get
breakfast i got an extra breakfast i
mean i haven't eaten in two [ __ ] days
i drink a gallon or two of water
i walk a little bit i get some sun i get
back and i see the
the lights blinking on the answering
machine
and i hit the [ __ ] thing and it's
like coco where the [ __ ] are you
i've been sleeping for three days [ __ ]
in blood
what the [ __ ] the matter you what were
those things call me back beep coco what
the [ __ ] i've been [ __ ] and [ __ ]
passing out
unbelievable what are you thinking peep
coco
call me back i'm on my way to the
hospital
i don't know what the [ __ ] you gave me
but you better have a good explanation
peep coco you got any more of those
pills they were tremendous right i'm
hearing all this [ __ ]
finally bro
one i call one of the guys back and he
goes bro what the [ __ ] did you give me
he goes i went and looked them up there
was no internet in those days i had to
go to the library
and it was what you give people when
they got an epileptic fit
oh my god
and dog i'm lucky those guys didn't die
because that's the first warning do not
like in big letters like those pills
will [ __ ] kill you we all lived holy
some people still hold the grudge
you can't say what are they gonna do
that's what happened to them did you
ever see him at the bar ever again after
that
yeah a couple people nobody [ __ ] i
still talk to two of the guys
that i gave the pills to
they live in san diego and vegas and
when i go to those towns they come to
the shows and whatnot so
it was it was just i ate them too
but i gave the rest of them to the dude
who kept asking me for
oh [ __ ] i must have had six left i gave
them to those kids that kid and he was
popping like one one
then he started popping twos
and here i was dead he was eating two of
them like chewing on like [ __ ] those
pills are tremendous i wish you could
get more
and then one night like maybe a month
later dog we went out
there was no blow we got pretty [ __ ]
up at the bar another one i'm not very
proud of
it was one of those crazy nights bro the
cop showed up at john mary's
the owner told him spitting his bad
and told him to get the [ __ ] out of the
joint
somebody went to buy a cigarette and the
thing got stuck and he put his hand
because he remember the old cigarette
machine yeah you got to pull the thing
he put his hand through the glass the
[ __ ] marbles i mean for a while there
we were having a
one night it snowed it was one of those
new york snows
like a foot and a half two feet of snow
no newspaper delivery this is before the
internet lee
this is when every morning you depended
on those two newspapers the local and
the daily news
you were either a post or daily news but
the post made up their own sport lines
so we don't deal with those [ __ ]
thieves we go with the daily news
doug there were days two of those two
days they didn't come milk used to get
delivered in those days you know milk
you you tried to drive everything was
shut down so we couldn't even get the
lines on games and i never forget one
night we had just gotten coke like even
coke
coke deals like bro i can't get the car
up
i'll never forget me and this kid darren
rego god rest assault was sitting by the
window like lookouts we weren't looking
at we were just looking at the snow how
beautiful it was
got a couple drinks
and what the [ __ ] do we see right as
easy and dude
this is northern new jersey 1983.
the [ __ ] is wrong with you
we see a dude
cross-country skiing like just perfect
for like this cross-country skate the
guy next to me is a future murderer
he don't know it yet but i do that's a
murderer in this guy
all i did was look at him he goes
what the [ __ ] is he thinking let's get
out there
you know us two went out there first i
thought we were just going after the run
and just go
get the [ __ ] out of our neighborhood and
[ __ ] right
now
like this is switzerland for the
olympics you [ __ ] momo listen not
only did i run out when people saw me
run out
of them ran out and they're like what
the [ __ ] fury
no no no no darren now there's two feet
of snow on the sides and [ __ ] there's
snow
was crazy
i didn't think i thought darren was just
gonna chase him like 50 yards we'll get
the [ __ ] out of our neighborhood and
it's a little snowball adam [ __ ] no
damn when i by the time i look at these
guys and look back
diamonds 30 yards from the guy and he's
like hey you [ __ ] [ __ ] sucking he's
yelling so now we're like oh no
we take off people are falling down
by the time we get over that darren's
punching the [ __ ] out this guy i mean
the ufc type shots to the head [ __ ]
those concussions this [ __ ] this guy was
down
daryn's hitting them with [ __ ] elbows
and a paw paw the guy's head's going i
mean this is [ __ ] up this is why i
knew he was a murderer
you know what i'd known for years his
mom was dying to cancer they got the
voice
you know what i'm saying he had this
thing
he was juicing there was the beginning
of his juicing
we had him doing push-ups at bars we
would take him to bars and go down and
do a bump listen come here
do do ten push-ups and
pose for these people who the [ __ ]
they're dealing with north bergen
representing that you go really what do
you think yeah yeah all of us are
talking mentor what are you crazy
do a bump
do some push-ups warm up and do poses
and we'd make them do crabs and [ __ ]
i i
till this day i miss that craziness in
the east coast like you do that little
little neighborhood you grew up in it
was a safety because you were like with
your friends that you grew up with
but this you know some of the none of
this [ __ ] was safe
you know
but it's fun it was never seen dangerous
in the moment
i'm so sorry
so
darren beats the [ __ ] out of this guy
this seems dangerous hold on we drag
them oh good 30 feet
to a bmw and we throw them over the
fence darren closer
wait i have one question this is one
question
he's still on his feet
oh no
[Music]
it was classic [ __ ] classic
and then they sold the skis none of them
no no no this is how beautiful this one
is
he throws him over tyron jumps over
and starts [ __ ] taking the flag from
the vfw to turn around his ankle
darren's like [ __ ] this guy's going
to be missing an action or whatever he
piles more snow on top of him
we go back in the bar
by that time the coke shows up we do
bumps we celebrate we forget all about
the whole [ __ ] situation
about an hour later
we see [ __ ] red lights everywhere
right
and then we got the bar surrounded
come out right now we know who you are
so i look around the bar i got like
[ __ ] two eight balls in my pocket i'm
going down
but i look around and i see i know one
of the cops
my job is to get out there and get to
him
if i can get to him i'll put this eight
ball in my hand and shake his hand and
tell him we're good i don't know what
happened to you you know say get the
[ __ ] out of here master plan i'm sitting
there cops are getting out of that car
but they're not running in like swat
yeah they're like what is this a [ __ ]
joke
you know they're all in the middle of
the street the door opens up my idiot
friends walk out i see the cops rushing
them i get out the right time i see my
buddy hey what's going on i put the
eight ball on this side oh no we were
here hanging out he goes all right get
the [ __ ] out of here walk this way as
we're walking this way
i don't know what the cops are in there
for i got forgotten i'm so [ __ ] up
and i look at the police car and the
dude is in the back with blankets on
just [ __ ] shaking
and we just walk right past them
the fact that
i love how you were like why just he was
just skiing
what was what's wrong with you not done
it was 1983 in the neighborhood
especially cross country i didn't even
know what that was
if you're going to ski i wanted you to
ski like james bond holes and [ __ ] and
her majesty's secret service i don't
want you to [ __ ] i imagine like you
chased him out of town through snowballs
adam
jesus christ
nah dawg this is you another starly not
really
but it's easy talk to me brother you got
me this this star that got me [ __ ] up
no i love it i could tell it hit you a
little bit oh yeah yeah this thing you
were looking for oh my god
i haven't done one of those in a very
long time another one i'll take one for
the road i want to go for the road oh
thank you so much never know what
happens on friday night the cars are
running is easy i'm sorry
not this weekend i'm on the road where
are you this week oh uh phoenix stand up
live
i love that club
that's so weird you like it
i think it's too big for me yeah but it
bothers me it's it does it is big it
bothers me that's what bothers me that's
number one
number two
jesus christ you want your comedy to be
pure
really i gotta hear music that's my only
beef yeah i know give me the respect i
deserve i've been fighting in the mud
all my [ __ ] life i've been on the set
for six years taking orders from the
kids i could chop up in half you know
what i'm saying yeah they don't even
have to win of me now you want me to
come down here and while i'm on stage i
gotta hear music you know
it's uh but it's a great venue it's yeah
it's a nice big big big hotel is nice
but yeah the music next door a lot of
these places though are like have those
music i don't know cars no bars i don't
think the audience can hear it though
yeah but we hear it
but it doesn't you know that's what they
got let me tell you someone think about
the improvs
they invest in their sound systems
right yeah they really work hard
and if there's a flaw and you tell them
they're gonna fix it yeah and then they
call you the next day and they'll go hey
we fixed that thing you're like it's a
[ __ ] that was last night i'm good
yeah i'm in phoenix you know i've been
[ __ ] all the dina yeah they um
they you know they curtain off that
little back part if it's not there's no
one back there but i like that room i
just like i've always had fun there i
like tempe too
i just came up in tempe yeah it's
sentimental i remember i did it a couple
times the old before they reconstructed
it i like that that was always a fun
like uh
a pride destination yeah your pride
destinations in economy like when you
first got into county that the the three
cities that san francisco
san francisco if i was like all right
i'm gonna do san francisco denver
comedy works i heard always heard was
unbelievable
cap city in austin
dc improv
comedy cellar in new york
those are the ones that i heard that
were like you know
have you been you do the comedy seller a
lot no i've never done the comedy seller
in new york
but you know those are the ones that
i've always heard were unbelievable
is that the ones i
mean like no no but my question to you
is like
when i went to boston when i got a
recommendation to play a club outside of
boston
i knew i was going to get somewhere
like comedy-wise like they didn't know i
wasn't mantra you all
this was a pivotal city for me there's
always those pivotal cities where you're
when you're starting out yeah that's the
question like chicago and zany's in
chicago i built an audience up there
remember selling out there before
anywhere else the show took place in
chicago
and then i think that that's where my
audience got
biggest fastest
i like that club you know the downtown
one's cool i really like that one
but that's a fun that was like my first
big area
zany's in chicago
boston's was good boston was great i
remember when i did the wilbur i was
excited about that
that was that was exciting yeah he got
me excited about it that was a good i
just uh
there's one part of this thing when you
hate when the business becomes involved
you like the purity of just you yeah you
just want to go to the store and do that
fifteen dollar setting get out of there
and not have to worry about a check or
if it was sold out or not sold out and
who's pissed and who's not pissed well
well for me the reason why i like i was
excited to do that for him for joey to
do the wilbur was because i went there
as a kid like that's the big theater in
boston yeah like what big did you guys
do like a big theater in jersey or
something that was like with that you
went to as a kid that was pretty cool
i mean the coliseum but no one ever dice
i think did the coliseum no i'm not like
did you do anything
have you gone back home oh governor's on
long island
they put me on their comedy wall of fame
from long island which i thought was
really cool i like that club too i like
that clothes yeah
um
that was like that was the home club
that my parents would go see comedy at
when i first got moved to l.a i had to
go to new york for something this is
such a weird
it was a weird trip i went to new york
and i was supposed to showcase the
governors it was like a tuesday night
but then the manager called me and said
you know what it's a dark club it had
become [ __ ] up for a while and those
guys took it over and said it again and
stuff
but that was a weird trip because i
turned down that
i turned on another showcase like the
comic strip like this manager i had knew
that comedy thing new york city uh-huh
but he also told me
to make a tape of myself
that would stand up while i was here and
drop it off in hbo that they're casting
a show called the sopranos
and i remember going like okay so
why would i go to a song about singers
i was like [ __ ] that [ __ ] i'm not going
down there
[Music]
i knew you were at the store when you
were
auditioning your ass off yeah and being
number two always number two for like a
year you were going in and making the
screen test they'd take you to lunch
rub your feet
you messed up the presents you used to
sign the paperwork that says how much
money you're going to make before you go
in there remember that last audition
so that way in case you know they like
you they can't
you know negotiate then so you knew you
were like [ __ ] here we go
it's either this or nothing let's go do
it
him and i leave went through like a year
of this auditioning hell and we would
talk to each other every night at the
comedy store about the audition the
casting director
which ones we liked who was there yeah
that we do this was a different time for
auditioning than what's going on right
now
yeah i mean i really don't i haven't
done it for a little bit but the pilot
season this year is going to be
interesting i heard you don't really
test in front of the audience like in
front of the people anymore sometimes i
heard you do it on tape
which is a different thing
nerve-wracking to like go in there and
do it in front of them
listen call me in let me know what time
on friday afternoon
let's make it close to one o'clock yep
give me the [ __ ] sides on wednesday
let me smoke a [ __ ] 20 and i'll get
back to your friday at 1. watch me go to
work go ahead call some names in there
and i guarantee you'll have my headshot
on the wall i don't know if you'll give
me the job for practical matters for
whatever yeah nobody knows who i am
whatever but trust me
that's what i know how to do
that's what i got really good at i got
so good at it
then i got addicted to booking but not
wanting to shoot when they call me for
wardrobe i go god damn it
and so were you you got addicted to it
for a while you really got into it the
acting the producer sessions the second
session
[ __ ] the second sessions yeah and i
remember saying to you it's a game of
numbers
and it's so weird how it was like it was
like you lost
in your mind it seemed like you lost 100
jobs in a row
and all of a sudden boom at fx call
calling the day you were for this season
yep it's unbelievable but yeah there was
those years of just being like i went i
got to this level this year i didn't
book one the next year you book a pilot
doesn't go
just you know the whole thing where
you're like i'm in the room
trying the best i can
trying to figure it out as i go along
who we would see in the rooms who we
would test for what roles i remember
julie ashton
bringing both of us in oh right now you
should be in my reader
because that's all i can think about
right now is julie ashton yeah like when
i think about my comedy career
three pilots
four pilots she put me in yeah she's one
of them one of them at five in the
afternoon
call time was seven
fifteen hundred go to fox
nypd 2063
that didn't have a chance in hell you
understand me rocket ships in new york
people getting shot by lasers i was a
newspaper guy good luck oh my god
i think these stars how many stars did i
have i had one star that's all you need
it's amazing it's uh i would i think
till today julie still calls me in i
hope to see her
16 years later
that's crazy
that we've been working for that lady
for 16 years everything would happen
with me she called to say hey we're good
i love you
she's a good woman
let me see
i booked lewis but she booked me and
lewis
whatever's pilot oh yeah she booked me
an nypd 2069.
that's amazing
she booked me in uh
happy hour
oh really then they cut me out after the
pilot takes the [ __ ] that they were
thanks to [ __ ] those people now i see
them around
and they can't even look me in the
eyeball and should that but they were
improv actors though
two of them were commercial actors
now they're [ __ ] the five people in
that show and they couldn't hire the
right janitor
finally i had to bring uncle joey to
school and when the school of comedy and
they their [ __ ] jaws dropped they
didn't at that time at that time i was
that good already on stage i had done
the longest yard there's nothing three
[ __ ] you guys are [ __ ] amateurs
compared to what the [ __ ] dungeons
i've been
you know what i'm saying i remember the
the uh the longest yard everyone coming
out after hanging out with us at the
comedy store that was in the movie and
saying how unbelievably [ __ ] funny
you were the entire time down there oh i
was killing killing [ __ ]
killing everyone
i was killing i wasn't you were gone
where were you guys new mexico new
in new mexico
for like five days i just watched
listen like god blessed me whoever
they called me down there and i got to
tell you something i was kind of pissed
after i got down and lifted the schedule
like
yeah you're not even shooting until next
week
yeah what am i here for but they were
giving me per diem yeah a buck of the
day mm-hmm they had me in [ __ ] the
hotel
santa fe which is
nice lucille ball that's where everybody
goes brad pitt that's the best there is
indians [ __ ] tremendous food you know
just tremendous yeah good food
they had me in that room for [ __ ]
seven days before i did anything
so for the first three or four days i
went to this down there you know
[ __ ] like i was happy
i smoked the number yep i brought you
with the vibe of the notepad i broke my
signs over just to make believe i was
going over my side but not really
i'm making notes to what the [ __ ] i'm
saying how you're shooting this
how he's working with the actors i was
you know i didn't know
wait think i was doing i was doing one
line for [ __ ] thing before that
yeah my first scene was gonna be like a
[ __ ] eight liner yeah in an ensemble
with eight gorillas talking at one time
that's like uh yeah what's that first
line i do uh
whatever the [ __ ] it is uh
trio yeah what the [ __ ] the trio yeah
yeah that was it dawg and all of a
sudden there was eight people i'd never
done that before yeah wait there's so
many teachers i don't do that they teach
you how to do me and you i'm new york
city i can do like i love getting
interviewed by the cops that's my number
one job you gotta get interviewed by the
cops i'm knocking off brandon that's how
good i am at then
no but we were both fighting for our
lives trying to get acting jobs yeah
anything movies
we had conversations about [ __ ] at night
by that point i had figured out it was
[ __ ]
wasn't even about your performance it
was just about there was so many many
getting factors variables different ways
it didn't matter what you know just luck
of the thing that worked out at the
right time
the stars always have to be alive yeah
joe you always talk about focus so why
why can't you why why didn't you just
focus all of your energies on stand-up
like why are you even worrying about
acting
because at that point my stand-up was
going nowhere
my stand-up was going nowhere and i
figured out that montreal didn't want me
there was no comedy agents wanted me
there was no comedy managers that spoke
to me but
if i could act i could go through the
back door
by the time they catch up with my
stand-up my standard will be ready for
them
so if i could act little by little see
like i told you or somebody else in this
town as a young comic you come here you
ain't dick you could be the funniest guy
at all those open mics they're gonna
promote you to be a regular at the store
you ain't addicted you book a commercial
yep that's how i remember it okay
because tell them why because now you
become viable yeah that's what you
become you're letting me know i'm at
home one night i own the improv embraer
you've been bugging me for a year to do
a guest spot
you're still watching commercials you're
still watching commercials it's 11 30
you're stoned
and there's steve runner's easy on a
[ __ ] motorola commercial
during the 11 o'clock news holy [ __ ] i'm
gonna book him one of those [ __ ]
weekends that we can't get rid of you
know and they'll give you an emcee spot
yep because
they know now that you might go
somewhere mm-hmm you just became
somebody by booking that kind of like
being part of a club that's it when i
booked the taco bell commercial it was
all over like people were talking to me
i booked a pilot for cbs nobody knew
about it yep
even if you don't talk like if you don't
talk you're cool
yeah yeah mcdonald's was my first
commercial i put the mcdonald's i want
to take any book a commercial in those
days i booked it in 2005.
so four years
three and a half years
how often were going on auditions i mean
the first year it was like they barely
they send you out on like one every if
you didn't book it right away like one a
month
and then and then you know you get like
you get a call back or a couple
callbacks and then before you know it
you're they're like you're in call backs
all the time and then you book one then
you go you know then they're like all
right look i remember judah freelander
booked like 87 commercials yeah
like unless before he became and they
take you seriously yeah okay let's i've
seen you before have i seen you yeah now
you hop over from commercial actor
to real actor which is tough sometimes a
lot of people get like that a t guy
you'll never see you'll see him in the
spring commercial yep but you'll never
see him in the movie opposite jokusto or
[ __ ] johnny bananas or something like
that
it's crazy how i knew that i would
eventually like everything i would get
one line one line one line then i went
on a three-liner
tear for a while and then i went in a
five-liner only with credits rolling yep
the first um i went on a three movie
tear where the credits ran through me in
the first [ __ ] five minutes of the
movie i remember going from commercials
i'd done two commercials and i booked a
guest star on the show called kitchen
confidential with bradley cooper it's a
fox show and i was going to play a
banker who was running out on a check
like a wall street guy and he used like
ran the restaurant so he would run after
me and call the cops so it was one like
one scene but four lines and then i run
out the door so
i remember hanging out on set and trying
to see what the difference is it between
this is the same thing as a commercial i
only done a commercial you know they
didn't treat you very well so then i did
this and they're covering angles and
this and that the director's like more
wait is it talking to you this is the
reality show like the reenactment no no
no this was a real scripted show oh okay
yeah and so he would you know like just
trying to learn about the differences
like what's the next level gonna be like
all right this is television this is
what this feels like it's different than
commercials they kind of have more money
take more time on things they kind of
move it differently so i remember going
from that to that and kind of learning
the level as i got there
you know i wanted to take you to get
the league you that was in 2009
nine years ago yeah i've done a couple
pilots i did one show that went for like
12 episodes
in 2000
uh
six
and then a couple pilots that didn't go
after that then that paul blart movie
was between that two
that was great because that was another
one
in boston
for three months we shoot the movie i
get there i have like 10 day gaps
you know but you know my girlfriend
would come out and fly out and hang out
you know so it was great
hanging out in the hotel but
yeah those big breaks are fun but kevin
used to give us all this [ __ ]
the burlington mall right the burlington
mall he would give us some legal
seafood's right on the left right i used
to [ __ ] eat there dude i grew up i
grew up with illegal seafoods in the
high top seats right at the front it was
the best job because we would uh would
they realize because the mall was still
open we kind of shoot kevin's stuff at
night so i had like businessman hours my
call time wasn't till noon
and then i would work till
eight
be home back at the hotel by 8 30 and
nice dinner you know and then get into
the night whatever i wanted to do
have long stretches off four or five
days off it's [ __ ] great and they
just paid your run of film it's awesome
that and then the league
it was a different
i get quite i just started getting calls
about a week and a half and i'll be like
hey yeah mm-hmm you've been going off a
pile of season probably go i didn't even
know it was pilot season yeah just
started
and uh i wasn't like at this point i'm
not even concerned named why i used to
concern myself i think i gave up about
five years ago six years ago i finally
said this is the reality of it
unless i write a show or somebody writes
me in the very beginning a producer that
believes in me
this ain't gonna happen i don't want to
go and go halfway through them book it
then you're too funny for him
so i replace you with [ __ ] white
johnny
and there you are and their [ __ ]
friends you don't say [ __ ] that and
that's what you know that's part of the
business a lot of great people listen
joe rogan got the role because ray
romano got fired
how [ __ ] crazy is that sir you figure
it out
didn't leah remini get something on
friends and then yeah
really yeah something like that i
thought that's what happened
she wasn't she was on the original
friends cast
maybe you know someone always gets fired
at the table read those table reads they
don't do them for to just hear
everything out loud they're doing it
because i remember when i sat down on my
first one ever
kurt fuller who was playing the dad on
the show it's like old an old character
actor ghostbusters 2 right you've seen
him all over the place
he turns and he looks at me goes how do
you feel i'm like great i'm excited
about this he's like you know
someone always just give it your all
cause someone always gets fired one of
us is gonna be gone after this [ __ ]
thing and he was right they fired one of
the dudes
after the show and you know you find out
on the way to the your car
that's how quick it happens
you you're done with the bagel after
everyone says hello great job everyone
you walk towards your car by the time
you get to your car your agent's on the
phone hey we gotta talk
what happened in there
jesus and she auditioned for monica yeah
but she didn't get it oh she didn't get
it i [ __ ] got fired
from a movie in jamaica which i didn't
care and they wanted
it was a sag movie but they didn't
really get the contract and sag nobody
sent the sag rep
to [ __ ] jamaica it was like a nudist
colony
what else did i get fired from i got
fired from something else
a movie that i got with a bunch of
[ __ ] moocs i didn't want to do it and
i just called him and said i'm done done
and we go you're fired okay [ __ ] it but
then
one of my most [ __ ]
infamous finds that nobody knows about
is i got fired
from a telemundo show
what from a cuban telemundo show and
guess what about two years ago i'm in
the park where my daughter and my wife
were walking around the park and the guy
sees me goes hello how are you and all
of a sudden
he goes can i talk to you for a second i
just want you to know i never saw you
again after that time
when they fought you had nothing to do
with me one of the producers just did
not like you
and i was like okay thank you for
telling me 18 years later which i never
lost nothing they paid for my after oh
really it was a thousand dollars after
that thousand dollars there was a joint
or something yeah and then that was like
98
i went down to the audition on a monday
i guess my spanish got away with it but
at the table read
i like the what is that like the
blocking yeah i just ate the big dick
and then they had a minute of pause
and these cubans started talking you
know
and i'm like what part of it where are
you from they're like this place
and these were all these cubans that
were high level that thought they were a
high level no i didn't grow up in
union city we grew up in
914 rockland county because my father
didn't want to be around cuba those type
of mothers you know
that was a weird
[ __ ] those [ __ ]
what's up dog what are you looking at me
are you still going through changes no
i'm i'm now i'm hot
are you sweating i'm sweating i'm always
sweating it's like i'm gonna give some
shout outs and we'll get you out of here
alex wiley in the house
my man austin meyer is my little brother
there
making it happen stefan kelly tsp bud
and roach
my main man one by one podcast
bobby sharon and crystal chris murphy
andrew nan diaz and chris trent in the
[ __ ] house also
while i got you let me tell you
something
tell them about siso link
oh i love see so okay so here's the deal
they have all the great comedy you want
so i i like specials so i know they have
uh joey i know they have stanhope i know
they have a couple more coming up which
are pretty great um
and but what i really like is they have
all of and i like parks and recreation
they have that rory skova's specials on
there too rory scoville specials on
there they have roy kilmartin specials
on there what i'm what i'm really
looking forward to seeing is that uh
paul tompkins he has a show on there i
wanna i wanna see that when i i um they
i
i'm going through their catalog and i'm
just really impressed with all the stuff
they have
well i'm happy that you like it brother
because i love it too i'm happy i want i
chose them stop settling for open mic
comedy
when the legends are at your fingertips
cso puts you on the guest list for
exclusive comedy shows from legendary
comics and today's top talent with new
exclusive specials from nick apollo and
uncle joey
myself doug stanhope and the new special
from nick you don't have to stand in
line and shout out 30 bucks at your
local comedy club to see us ceso has
exclusive specials from them and many
more that you can enjoy from your couch
on your favorite device plus the drink
minimum
is up to you you understand me nobody
bothers you nobody knows nothing all
right
with cso you get unlimited access to
cecil original series next day late
night hilarious stand-up specials
binge-worthy classics including 42
seating
42 seasons of saturday night live
including the pilot the entire monthly
python collection the it crowd and much
much more with cso you get binge work
classics british cult comedy original
series like harman quest and bajillion
dollar properties not to mention the
entire snl library including new
episodes that day
after they air do me a favor
ready for the punchline ceso is 399 per
month no joke
399 per month for all the comedy you
want anytime anywhere ad free access cso
content from anywhere anytime using ios
android roku
apple tv
amazon fire tv stations
window and xbox live but guess what this
is what i'm gonna do just go to cso.com
right now
sign up for one month free with promo
code you ready joey at checkout
who's better than you again this is the
best offer ceso has gone right now all
right i can take care of you one month
of free of laughing your ass off comedy
including uncle joey
at cso by using promo code joey j-o-e-y
that cso.com spells s-e-e-s-o
dot-com
promo code joey ceso.com promo code joey
all right and you get to hang out with
uncle joey do me a favor go over there
press the button watch the special watch
nick apollo and watch laurie kim one
learn something about
comedy from these people not from me i
got bad habits
anyway
back to my main man steve brenda's easy
up on long island when did you get the
comedy you're in stephen it's easy
after college
i was uh wanted to perform every night
so i started writing jokes and i was
like i'm going to try open mics
went to new york comedy club
did the open mic there a little bit
when he was this
nine two thousand oh okay yeah white gun
from the new york comedy club i was
lingering yeah
oh really it's back now i heard it's
pretty nice
there's so much comedy in new york right
now when you go there if you call five
clubs they'll put you up mm-hmm you know
there's tons of action in new york you
could do five six clubs a night five
times
i'm too old
how many spots do you would you do in a
night and be like i'm too much three
three
but they have to be fun yeah three good
ones three i don't care there's 60
people
yeah as long as they're fun i don't care
the first one's gonna bomb i want to
bomb the first one because i got two to
redeem myself
yeah you don't want to laugh i don't
give a [ __ ] i got three more like you
can you do three hour shows a night now
would you i know
between the reefer the age the memory
listen one of the worst things on stage
is when you're saying a joke
and you don't know if you said that joke
before the
show before or you've already said it
already i know that's happening
let me tell you something
i was in lunch i was at the miami improv
tuesday through sunday with three shows
on saturday
if anybody went through the training i
earned it okay they had the improv in
the late 90s got this bug three shows
yeah three shows the late ones started
an hour late
what headline of this 42 minutes on a
saturday i got the sold out crowd yeah
i'm going to keep it tight the late show
would start at 1. those people are happy
now you got to do another [ __ ] show
you wouldn't get out of there till three
on sunday night you're at the bar
waiting to go up your central nervous
system
it's terrible shot you don't want to
even say your [ __ ] jokes
and guess what you gotta do your [ __ ]
thing get a check go to your hotel room
and go back because you gotta fly to l.a
do laundry
feed the cat clean the litter box and
leave on tuesday morning and do it all
over again in san antonio oh [ __ ] three
shows on saturday i did three shows in
columbus at the funny bone on st
patrick's day was a saturday i did three
shows the third show was that one of
those ones where i was like have i told
this joke before did that understand
that's that's
you know because maybe you're like
are they are they laughing i feel like
they're laughing like they heard it
before and they're laughing at me lee
you think you're going crazy for a
minute
it's that quick that you you get to as
you're saying the joke
you don't know if they're laughing
because you're [ __ ] up yup sometimes i
eat a star up deadly it's the second
show
i got two three stars in me dawg my mind
stops are floating you know the second
show already you prove your point in the
first show so the second show i'm gonna
take a couple [ __ ] jabs
i'm gonna take some detours yeah i'm
gonna take you down some dark streets
because it's the 11 o'clock show you
know what i'm saying yeah
yeah that's so much fun and i like doing
that because then i go oof i didn't do
any of those jokes yep
thank you [ __ ] god
i didn't have to do any of those jokes
all over again i'm sitting up there
going did i do this joke did i do this
joke it's 11 o'clock at night i've been
up since seven
my first joint was at 7 30. what are the
odds nobody can withstand that memory
thing it's 10 o'clock
remember we could smoke when i smoke all
day and show up at 11 and do two shows
no not too many people that most people
the second show that that camera hits
you
when that [ __ ] you get on that stage
and depending on how the audience is you
get instant anxiety sometimes from me
man
i fought a little bit this year and i'm
okay with it now the store gives it to
me
yeah when i go to the store sometimes as
i'm walking up those steps
if i eat an edible i forget and i run up
those steps and i get a little anxiety
after six steps
and it takes me to a different place i
gotta sit in mitzi share
that my nerves come down
how many seasons does the [ __ ] league
go we went seven you loved it loved
doing it where did you shoot
in on location in the valley usually and
then a couple days downtown sometimes
the bar was downtown that we shot at
some office stuff downtown
but yeah valley it was a blast i love
doing it
i like going to work you know
i like this you know it was same crew
same people for the most part it was fun
but yeah you know would you want to do
it again i would like to do a show as i
mean i would love to do a show as fun as
that
another six seven year run would be fun
on another fun show how fun would it be
to get on lauren order down be one of
the cops brothers easy hometown guy
just yeah for your contract this [ __ ]
uh a junior detective junior detective
donnelly
yeah i i bro that's a dream right there
i mean being an investor like steve
sharipa landed another one on blue
bloods god bless that god god bless him
yeah
god bless you that's all you can bounce
to another one then that's it once a
show ends you take a year off
you spend some of that genus you hide
some of it you buy some shoes
and you tell your agent listen
[ __ ] there's some show out there
wait for me put some writing together i
know you got another writer on staff
you got something on staff you got
somebody over there write them in well i
think didn't you play a d.a on the
league yeah i played a lawyer
so that's it yeah yeah i could do it
again yeah experience [ __ ] yeah
a damn one-on-one assistant
yeah one of those chicago shows chicago
law they'll make next
[ __ ] yeah i'll do that
there's nothing it's it'd be fun
if you make it fun i mean as long as
it's not the last couple times i've
worked except marin like i worked
network television
i wasn't feeling it
no
i wasn't feeling it why it wasn't like
uh
i used to be excited about doing network
television dog in the beginning i got
thrown to the wolves i did a couple of
shows that were live
i went from [ __ ] doing co-stars to
doing a live
mad tv with people in the audience are
you [ __ ] crazy when did i do
juilliard
remind me when did i when did you ever
go to a plane you see me in julian
you know these people understand what
comedy star economics
you know what bro i may have felonies
i snorted blow you know what i'm saying
i had an ex-wife
it's tough to let these people
understand
that would calmly store cameras yeah
we're there from the core from the 11 45
spots
we played tricks on people we lit what's
his name on fire in the bathroom
yeah what's his name what's his name you
know
you got your dick sucked down there you
got drunk there's a [ __ ] down
there passed out you live in the house
huh no i never lived in the house now
you had friends that were lost now down
there
you know you're a cow
sometimes i feel bad about my comedy and
[ __ ] on my boys
mitzi made me a [ __ ] regular i don't
know what the [ __ ] you [ __ ] better
step back and [ __ ]
[ __ ]
yeah
yeah like you know very proud i remember
like going on mad tv
and them telling me what i got to do and
me going home and going
i better call my age in the morning and
tell them that i'm sick as a dog and i
can't do this
and then i would always go back to like
whoa whoa whoa
i followed [ __ ] what's his name not
aj jamal
is how his name is yeah there's aj jamal
smooth black comedian which is so funny
with dreads
no
but you know i was following don maren
getting buried
yeah in the main room getting buried and
then going into no confidence
at the 11 45 spot in the original room
which in those days was tighter
it was more more gladiator type
there were more savages in there they
come up from the [ __ ]
burrows of orange county and watch
comedy now it's a lot of more tourists
you know
it's so famous now because of podcasts
and stuff it's famous everywhere
i think that's what it is every people
make trips now
i've talked to audience members who make
trips
they're just solely there because they
want to meet you and
business it's it's [ __ ] amazing they
come on business yeah they're checking
at this uh not the standard uh yeah the
standard down there where somewhere
close to over there
and they walk and they walk through
restaurants and they go to sushi and
then they come back to the economy store
and it's great to know that people
listen to us all over the [ __ ] world
and this translates yeah but we're doing
translates you're starting a podcast i
am i start actually it launches next a
week from tomorrow what's the name of
the podcast hear me this book
with steve ren is easy i don't read i
don't really read books or have read all
the books i'm supposed to have read so
i'm gonna have guests on tell me about
their favorite book we'll talk about it
while they read it you know and then
we'll just jump off from a conversation
from there you want to practice on uncle
joey real quick
oh you have you got a book that you
think you found the books what book
would you would you pick i'd love to
have you on
the wha
what what do you want me to read
he's he's been telling me to read a book
for like yeah what book did you suggest
to have him to weed
the war of art the war of art stephen
pressfield stephen pressfield it talks
about resistance and what makes you not
want to do
the things that are going to lead you to
a better life how old is it
it's been around a couple years he wrote
a couple movies and stuff real
interesting story but he's one of us
that got sick and tired of getting beat
up and he wrote and he figured out what
is what stops you from
doing what you're supposed to do it's an
interesting book
but the other day i was looking at this
[ __ ] book i got
this is one of those books that i read
that i had to put down a couple of times
it was so scary
and i read some great books one of my
favorite books about wings of eagle
the story of [ __ ] your boy there from
texas the one that ran for president
with the red hair and the big ears when
we were kids
ross perel yeah that's a badass book
that's trump's uncle nobody knows it yet
obviously
that's ross pearl i do i remember like
being like what is that guy's deal he
was in the debates they let him in like
the big debates
and he was throwing he he kept saying
america these guys are paying for this
your money i'm paying for this with my
money yeah yeah he was ran but
you know what bro if you read
he was so modest and his publicity
people
never said read my book
i got it out there for free
really send me your book send me
your address i'm going to send you my
book and you tell me if you don't want
to be president of your country
and no i was a prison dog i didn't know
what to do
and for some reason i took this book off
the shelf
and when they moved me i kept the book
and i remember being there one night and
listening to [ __ ] black people
yelling all night and [ __ ]
in the middle of this there was like a
light i opened up the book unless i read
like the first 10 pages and for some
reason it just took me somewhere else
the next day i couldn't wait to wake up
to read it in the light
and it was basically about a guy who
made a bunch of [ __ ] getus
with this company and then they went to
iran and they got captured
so they came back to the states
and they had captured like four of the
office members
and then he went to kissinger and talked
to kissinger jesus but he made a promise
to the employees families that they
would be home
for christmas dinner
you know perrault was crazy so when
kissing just said we can't really go in
there you're on your own
this [ __ ] went and hired marlon
brando from apocalypse now
some crazy [ __ ] dude that shot could
go in heads no
to train his men
computer people whatever engineers
to bond together to go save the other
workers
and they took a plane over there they
broke down the location
and this army commander taught these
[ __ ] guys
these guys like lee
and guys like you
had a [ __ ] kill in 10 days
they really they went over they got a
building just like it and they practiced
taking over the building where the guys
were with regular people
and 10 regular guys they robin they had
to keep it going yep
they went in there they got the four
people uh tremendous dog ross perot
made his promise people dude he looks
like a little just like a little geek
doesn't matter that dude like an i.t guy
i do got pockets oh deep
yeah he was i remember at that time
reading what he was worth and what he's
worth
i really i remember danny harvey doing
it on saturday night live oh please he
was [ __ ] that you're gonna well made
for president but he just
the american just wasn't no no they
weren't ready for the third party no no
no no no some crazy dude he was ready to
blow he was saying it i wouldn't take
that stuff from nobody me i just press a
button that's it
once you say that on tv
people are like yeah
and some people in california like uh
press a button
well let's do that let's do that book on
the podcast
no but there's another book that you
alright it's called murder machine
and it's all about
the roy the mayo crew who roy the mayo
crew this sounds like a providence
boston crew no no they were out of
brooklyn out of canarsie and their main
thing was [ __ ]
stealing cars
changing the vins
changing the history and sending the
cars to iran and
all those countries and no matter what
the car was
they would get five g's per car fords
whatever it was
they were shipping over thousands of
cars a week what in shipping containers
and stuff shipping containers and [ __ ]
and they had crews of guys that would go
out at night look for particular orders
special orders i mean it was a girl all
right there was and then current rc is
known for chop shops and body shops so
the pizzas they need went out to those
guys
but roy demayo had chopped into uh
those people that make videos like if i
make a movie you duplicate them
oh um bootleg he had loaned the guy
money and they were bootlegging porno
and making a ton of money so roy the
mayo got it with them he killed the dude
no no roy the man was a savage
he killed him for a party
yeah the guy told him no i don't want
the partner [ __ ] killed him right he
became the movie
this guy was a [ __ ] animal how much
are duplicated well he was given
tribute to this [ __ ] high-ranking
gambino captain that they even have any
soldiers like this guy just kept them in
pork chops
but what people didn't know was that roy
demayo lent money and he also sold coke
but his main business was murder
and he had six dudes
he had these six dudes
that would hang out at this bar club
gemini
creepy [ __ ] bar but next to it they
had an apartment
and what their specialty was what they
carried on to i mean they went to john
gotti and said listen we want roy the
mayo gun and john gotti said what are
you asking me for
[Music]
i'm not [ __ ] nobody nobody till this
day i forget who the [ __ ] killed oh the
high-ranking captain because that was
the only guy he would talk to so that
this is his story
and what he would do what his [ __ ]
main thing was this is this is when
you know man all that [ __ ] to [ __ ]
fantasy
and i knew it was a fantasy as a young
guy these people that come up to you
listen if you give this guy money you're
with him really
i'm a cuban guy i don't want my money
they just want my money to [ __ ] tell
me
i got that speaker rule paying me 200
you know that's all [ __ ]
but this guy
they were doing drugs they were [ __ ]
stealing cars they were making money man
but when he got an inclination that you
did something against somebody invite
you to a party
and they go you want to do some blow
sure let's go next door i got this
cocaine that just came off the columbian
[ __ ] mule
he'd take it and as you walked in one of
them jumped out naked and stabbed yet oh
my god they stabbed you then the other
guy shot you and they put a [ __ ]
tower on your head and they dragged you
to the top like a nascar pit crew was
[ __ ] murdered it was a
machine
they put you in the tub
drain your blood hang you upside down
drain your [ __ ] blood
and then they go and start the pasta
that's my nightmare tonight why you why
you were [ __ ] draining
they go cut the lettuce and the [ __ ]
tomatoes and the whole thing why then
they'd make a sauce and by the time the
sauce was done
they go in the tub they get your drink
and they cut you into [ __ ] pieces
and put you into little garbage bags and
put you in one big garbage can that
night they take you around a different
day but just dump three bags of your
body in there here i had here rest here
they were doing it to [ __ ] everybody
dog that was this that was this thing
murder [ __ ] yeah if you're that good at
it
and that's where that dude came in that
crazy [ __ ] dude the iceman that's
right oh yeah
oh my god roy demayo that's why they
were the murder machine it's a [ __ ]
book
all right i love books
i know i'm i i don't i i'm not i'm
starting to read a little bit more and
[ __ ] read the good book you don't
have to go back like every time and read
pages over again to remember two pages
you know i comprehend my colors not my
comprehension was never that good in
school i always uh everything three
times imagine now what you do is you go
for quality
three or four pages at a time show the
[ __ ] thing before you start thinking
of your girlfriend in high school i used
to finger that that's the thing i'm
going off
dry cleaners i gotta go yeah i gotta go
to vermont this week i got no tickets
sold they want me to you know that's
what happens when you're reading all
right that's what i'm well i'm trying to
clear my mind
i'll be 40 this is young still but
there's so much on your mind those days
of though i couldn't wait to get out of
the plan
and take your [ __ ] sneakers off and
yeah
take a book out and go i got four hours
14 minutes
nobody's going to call home i don't
really give a [ __ ] about an audition on
email can't do nothing up in [ __ ]
yeah the sky here get it done
and you read 50 good pages of a book and
then last time you put a notebook next
to you
and while you're reading you think of
jokes maybe a new segue yeah something
like that amazing because you're
exercising your culture yeah you know
yep so i'm gonna have people on and do
books that i haven't read i'm looking
forward to it what's your list of books
that you're interested in reading i mean
there are there are his
like great gatsby
ones that like everyone's read
books like that but then like science
fiction books i'm not really into that
i want to have some people do that some
science fiction stuff autobiographies of
people i don't know
it doesn't really matter as long as
someone is
into the lamb's another one of my
favorites really cujo i read in prison
tremendous when i first read cool jordan
prison i couldn't sleep for like three
nights i was addicted what's that about
who joe stephen king about the dog the
[ __ ] oh he had a dog one crazy [ __ ] you
know crazy how he
[ __ ] with your mind that dude yeah yeah
i thought yeah that's always a finger in
the ears uh silence or lambs is
something that is a masterpiece
because i watched the movie 20 [ __ ]
times plus
and i've read the book five times six
times that's the only book ever
that that's exactly like the movie
[ __ ]
that that's just not an interesting [ __ ]
out there yeah all those years on the
road
when you come down from blow you gotta
get your mind back in shape i would go
to those borders books this way before
[ __ ] you can read online and [ __ ]
i drop 100 bucks in books
six or seven books yeah i never did that
i got to do that a biography
a
mobster one
i haven't read since school
yeah since i was like
they told me i had to read this exactly
and i i i i got through an entire
british which is okay yeah
an entire british literature course
without reading a book
the class was all discussion so i would
i would just
talk about discussion i ended up getting
like a b plus in the class
but they're like 600 page books
i still have them but i haven't had like
i've never even opened one of them i
also want to thank our boy for the
ball he gave you bob lolingus oh my god
oh my god this gave me a 700 [ __ ]
page book
what is the three lives of jimmy page oh
really
are you into it i'm tremendously into it
but what part are you into now i'm part
of no no am i into it no oh i need three
[ __ ] three in the hour flights yeah i
got them yep i got him all right i mean
it's this [ __ ] thing i don't even
think i'll go to security it's this
[ __ ] thick dog that's getting it
every day i look past it i read the
inside cover and i go wow can't wait
this is gonna be [ __ ] crazy man but
it's you know it's not like the old days
i've been you know i was in miami two
weeks of the shot
there's no show
no monday tuesday what do you think you
do you put the tv on medium you put cnn
mm-hmm and you read yeah you can smoke
dope on the balcony you eat a little
cuban food
where you got this weekend i'm gonna see
you phoenix phoenix yeah how much more
are you traveling phoenix then the
weekend after uh i'm in denver at the
comedy works downtown
then the weekend after charlotte at the
comedy zone and then i'm taking a little
while off those are like the three
hitters club boom boom boom i'm done
doing the next three weeks
i don't know how how have you now you've
drank like six waters i have to pee so
bad i drink three what do you think
you're dealing with it's unbelievable
i'm cuban marine trained it's amazing
there was a time like listen one time i
had an ounce of coke i was paranoid to
go to the bathroom and let the dog out
everybody got trained that weekend you
hold it in like a soldier
i have to [ __ ] like a [ __ ] shark
you want to go in there when i read the
ads and you come i just want to talk
about what's going on with comedy real
quick sure you're shooting a special
soon what's going on with you i mean i'm
on the road right now definitely
[ __ ] i love you i love you buddy
i love what you did i saw you as a young
kid
you had your doubts and awesome bam
you got on that show and you're in the
league and you're [ __ ] standing next
to people who matter and
it's not how many people you're shooting
so you're shooting that's right buddy
you're one of us i love you for a long
time i love you all thank you thank you
for having me i'll read this so you're
at the phoenix
stand about live this week stand up live
in phoenix thursday friday saturday yeah
thursday one show two no you're like me
no yeah no show sunday it's a super bowl
too yeah you're gonna sit there like i'm
on the look of a [ __ ] cracking jokes
to a bunch of people got free tickets to
the dinner get the [ __ ] out of here
can i thank the little longest is for my
gift really yeah good brother so i try
to really show it off because it's the
most amazing gift i've gotten in a long
time
this is a
like a crystal
baseball
with some dirt from the game that
it was david ortiz's last game at fenway
park
oh my god
look at this thing here's the camera if
i drop this on the thing i kill myself
here we go
it's just the it's the most amazing gift
thank you so much
i'm gonna write you a thank you note but
thank you don't worry about that i'm
gonna send him a little thing
i have to send another thank you let me
talk to you guys about something lee
what do you think about your watch
i love my memt watch man it's it's uh i
have the black on black one first of all
it looks great that's the first thing
that matters
not not only does it look great but it's
also lightweight it doesn't get in the
way when i'm working i love this watch
it's just uh it's my favorite the best
watch i have listen mbmt watches
was founded on the belief that style
shouldn't break the bank the
watchmaker's goal is to change the way
consumers think about fashion by
offering high quality minimalist
products and revolutionary prices with
over 500 000 watches sold to customers
in 160 countries around the world mvmt
watches has solidified itself on the
world's fastest growing
watch company okay listen valentine's
day is coming it's tough you don't know
what he wants you don't know what she
wants but thanks to mvnt watchers all
the gift anxiety disappeared with the
press of a button
these watches make the perfect purchase
for about anyone in your life guy or
girl and remember they started only 95
are you kidding me or what for 95
you can have a beautiful watch
on your wrist looking like a [ __ ]
doctor you've heard me talk about mvmt
watches and i'm sure you got yourself
one
but it's valentine's day get yourself a
nice watch for someone
special you know what i'm saying you
want the nookie you got to give a cookie
you follow me
listen
go to mvmt you can skip the crowds and
standing in crazy lines at the mall and
find the gift of love at the prices that
beat department stores all right
movement watches start at 95 at
department stores you're looking at 400
to 500 bucks all right movement figured
out that by selling online
they were able to cut out the middleman
and retail markup and providing the best
possible price classic design quality
construct construction and style
minimalism over 500 000 watches sold in
160 countries all right do me a favor
right now these watches are
tremendous you're gonna love how they
look on your wrist i'm gonna give you 15
off today with free shipping and free
returns by going to
slash
mvmtwatches.com
this watch has a real clean design
seriously i've been getting compliments
people love lee's watch now put it on go
to mvnt watches dot com slash church
again
you want a little nookie you got to give
her a cookie for valentine's day go to
mvmtwatches.com
church
join the movement
also
listen we're all different you're having
a you're having bad nights lately you
can't sleep you know night after night
two people lay on the same bed but when
it comes time to buy a new mattress only
one gets their way until now introducing
helix sleep where you can buy mattresses
online
customized for both of you for hundreds
of dollars instead of thousands go to
helixsleep.com
answer a few questions based on four key
preferences listen to me and the result
will be a custom sleep profile used to
build the most comfortable matches
you'll ever [ __ ] sleep on okay
your mattress will enviro at your door
in about a week and shipping is a
hundred percent free
and for couples helix customizes each
side of the mattress personalize to suit
each of your bodies the way you both
sleep who's better than that
you're going to sleep better okay helix
customers report 30 improvement in
overall sleep quality you've got 100
nights to try it and if you don't love
it they'll pick it up for free and give
you 100 refunds no questions asked okay
this is what everyone from gq magazine
to forbe they're all talking about
healing sleep go to helixleep.com
joey and get 50 off your order again
that's helixsleep.com
joey i got a half a yard that's 50 off
your order again healysleep.com
joey i want to thank my man
steve my little brother brother zizi
uncle joey for coming on the show
tonight and rocking us out he's going to
be in phoenix
don't forget you [ __ ] savages i'll be
at the nashville zany's
thursday eight o'clock that's all you
need to know one of my all-time
favorites it's taking me like two years
to go back
we're going deep this weekend so do
whatever you need to do get there i
don't know if i'm doing charlotte i
don't know if i'm going to atlanta i got
so many weeks
and i got to focus on different things
you understand me thank you for having
me on you can check out the podcast next
week if you're uh
on the february 7th all thing uh coming
out all things comedy
hear me this book with steve ren is easy
thank you uncle joey this is amazing
listen man go listen to his podcast
you're gonna love it he's a great kid
this is a very interesting [ __ ]
concept
what the [ __ ] take a chance columbus did
what else you gonna do in an hour and a
half sit there and dream someday i'm
gonna do a podcast go [ __ ] yourself i
wanna thank helix sleep i wanna thank uh
what the [ __ ] mvmt watches
i want to thank uh
cso tv
what is it dot what lee
see so see cecil.com and i believe it's
joey and you get one month free okay
csotv.com you get one month for free and
i want to thank my my heart my blood on
it.com remember ten percent off on
supplements
what is it lee
honor.com use promo code church to get
ten percent off
so it's promo code church c-h-u-r-c-h
all right listen have a great day we'll
talk to you in two days we had a great
night with steve rena's easy go watch
him in phoenix i'll see you in nashville
cox lisa who loves you more than me
nobody that's right [ __ ] have a
great day
stay black and beautiful
[Music]
bye
[Music]
shoot that voice